I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello everybody. Hi. Today we're going to be talking about Sex Ed. It is season seven episode four, written and directed by Paul Lieberstein. To be clear, Jen and I aren't going to give you a Sex Ed lesson. How do you know what's in my document? Oh no! You might be getting a little bit of a Sex Ed breakdown. Okay. It's possible. Hit me with
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。嗨。今天我们要讨论的是《性教育》。这是第七季第四集，由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧并执导。需要说明的是，珍娜和我不会给你上一堂性教育课。你怎么知道我的文档里有什么？哦，不！你可能会得到一点性教育的解析。好吧。有可能。给我来个
a summary. Here it is. Michael has a herpes scare, which prompts him to contact all of his ex-girlfriends and examine each relationship and its ending. I mean, that is a great pitch. I would have loved to see that card. What does that card say? Herpes? Dot, dot, dot. Michael contacts his ex-lovers. Meanwhile, Andy is going to take it upon himself to teach the importance of safe sex to his co-workers, which is really a gesture motivated by his feelings for Aaron. And we learned another thing about Andy's backstory. He was the R.A. in college. He has such a rich life. Well, today, instead of Fast Facts, we have a special guest. We're very, very excited. We adore her. You guys, we have Nancy Walls
总结。在这儿。迈克尔担心自己得了疱疹，这促使他联系了所有的前女友，并审视了每一段关系及其结局。我的意思是，这真是一个很棒的提议。我很想看看那张卡片。那张卡片上写着什么？疱疹？点，点，点。迈克尔联系了他的前任情人。与此同时，安迪决定亲自向同事们传授安全性行为的重要性，这实际上是一个出于他对艾琳感情的举动。我们还了解了关于安迪背景故事的另一件事。他在大学时是宿舍管理员。他有着如此丰富的生活。好吧，今天，我们没有“快速事实”，而是有一位特别嘉宾。我们非常非常兴奋。我们崇拜她。伙计们，我们今天请到了南希·沃尔斯
Corral today. That's right. It's Carol Stills, real estate agent and former lover of Michael Scott. She's with us today. We're going to ask her all about her time on the office. Here it is. Hello, Nancy. Hello, everybody. Yay. This is so exciting. We are here with Nancy Walls Corral, otherwise known as Carol Stills, the real estate agent. That's right. Nancy, in anticipation of this interview, I went back and watched every single Carol still scene of the entire series. We watched all of your episodes. Not only did we watch all of your episodes, we did a little outline. So we have a whole outline of Carol Stills. Oh my God. Because you know what? I think there are a few I haven't seen.
科拉尔。没错。她是卡罗尔·斯蒂尔斯，房地产经纪人，也是迈克尔·斯科特的旧情人。她今天和我们在一起。我们要问她所有关于她在《办公室》的时间。在这儿。你好，南希。大家好。耶。这太令人兴奋了。我们和南希·沃尔斯·科拉尔在一起，也就是卡罗尔·斯蒂尔斯，那位房地产经纪人。没错。南希，为了这次采访，我回去看了整个系列中卡罗尔·斯蒂尔斯的每一个场景。我们看了你所有的剧集。我们不仅看了你所有的剧集，还做了一个小纲要。所以我们有卡罗尔·斯蒂尔斯的完整纲要。天哪。因为你知道吗？我想有几集我还没看过。
Really? Well, if you have any questions. We are experts. Yeah. We're Carol experts now. I remember doing them, but I don't know if I've actually seen a few. Well, they were so much fun to re-watch. They're so delicious. Here's the first question we always ask our guests. How did you get your role on the office? Now, we know Steve pitched you for the role of Carol, but did you know he was going to do that? Like, how did it come up? You know, I think I remember when you guys were shooting the pilot talking to Greg Daniels, and he just said, you know, if anything ever came up, would you be interested in doing it? And I said, sure. Yeah. You know, I was
真的吗？好吧，如果你有任何问题。我们是专家。是的。我们现在是卡罗尔专家了。我记得拍过它们，但我不知道我是否真的看过几集。好吧，重温它们真是太有趣了。它们太美味了。这是我们总是问嘉宾的第一个问题。你是怎么得到《办公室》里的角色的？现在，我们知道史蒂夫推荐你出演卡罗尔这个角色，但你知道他会那样做吗？比如，这是怎么提出来的？你知道，我想我记得当你们在拍试播集时，我和格雷格·丹尼尔斯谈过，他只是说，你知道，如果有什么事情出现，你会有兴趣做吗？我说，当然。是的。你知道，我
open to it. And then I think Carol came up, Steve thought it would be good, and Greg thought it would be good. So that's how it happened. Because before this, you had been a cast member on Saturday Night Live. Yeah. You'd been on The Daily Show. Yeah. You studied improv at Second City in Chicago. With my teacher, Steve Carell. Oh, wow. Wait, what? Stasilist. That is awesome. I didn't realize he was your teacher there. I knew you were there at the same time. Yeah. No, no. I mean, Steve was sort of, he was on the main stage. He was a big shot. But a lot of time, the actors on the main stage would teach classes at the training center. So he taught one of my levels. You take five
对此持开放态度。然后我想卡罗尔出现了，史蒂夫认为这会很好，格雷格也认为这会很好。所以事情就是这样发生的。因为在此之前，你曾是《周六夜现场》的演员。是的。你曾参加过《每日秀》。是的。你在芝加哥的第二城学习即兴表演。和我的老师，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起。哦，哇。等等，什么？斯塔西利斯特。那太棒了。我没意识到他是你在那里的老师。我知道你们当时都在那里。是的。不，不。我的意思是，史蒂夫算是，他在主舞台上。他是个大人物。但很多时候，主舞台的演员会在培训中心教课。所以他教了我其中一个级别。你要上五
levels at the training center. So he was one of my teachers. We do not date until after. Respectable. Respectable. So how did your experience on the office compare to some of those other things? Well, certainly with Saturday Night Live, I mean, that's a live shot. You're shooting it live. And a lot of times with The Daily Show, that was in the studio in front of an audience. So the office is pretty much my only experience with, I mean, I guess would you call it a sitcom? I don't even know. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I had very little experience with that. So it was, you know, it was funny because I knew all you guys. So that was kind of nerve-racking coming into that. I mean, and I know you were all so incredibly nice.
个级别在培训中心。所以他是我的老师之一。我们直到后来才约会。值得尊敬。值得尊敬。那么你在《办公室》的经历与其他那些事情相比如何？嗯，当然对于《周六夜现场》，我的意思是，那是现场直播。你是现场拍摄的。而且很多时候《每日秀》是在观众面前的演播室里。所以《办公室》几乎是我唯一的经历，我的意思是，我想你会称它为情景喜剧吗？我甚至不知道。是的。是的。是的。我对那方面的经验很少。所以，你知道，这很有趣，因为我认识你们所有人。所以进入那个环境有点让人紧张。我的意思是，我知道你们都非常非常好。
So I wasn't worried about people being mean or anything. But I just, you know, I was worried about, you know, doing a good job for everyone, I guess. Oh, you did such a great job. And we, as a cast, we get so excited when you came to visit. Nancy, I remember this time. I don't know if you remember, but you were in here and makeup at the exact same time I was, and we were seated next to each other. And I was so excited. I just talked your ear off. I couldn't stop talking so much so that my makeup artist said, Angela, I'm going to need you to face me and not Nancy. Because he could only do like one side of my face because I was so excited to be talking to you. Oh, well, I was always excited to be there.
所以我并不担心人们会刻薄什么的。但我只是，你知道，我担心，你知道，为大家做好工作，我想。哦，你做得太棒了。而且我们，作为一个剧组，当你来探班时，我们非常兴奋。南希，我记得这次。我不知道你是否记得，但你当时在化妆，和我完全在同一时间，我们坐在一起。我太兴奋了。我一直在跟你说话。我无法停止说话，以至于我的化妆师说，安吉拉，我需要你面对我，而不是南希。因为他只能做我脸的一侧，因为我太兴奋能和你说话了。哦，好吧，我一直很兴奋能去那里。
And you know what? I want to say too, I brought a lot of family members and friends through that set for tours. And you guys were the nicest people, always, who always took time to say hi and take pictures. And I really appreciated that. I want you to know that. Oh, thank you. That's so nice. We got excited when people came out in the booties. We've shared this before to our listeners. We weren't on some big fancy lot where you came across other people. It was just us and a warehouse near like train station, basically. Yeah, we'd be like, oh my gosh, people we've never met or seen. It's like, you know, I feel like we were like a puppy and a new person came into the house and you just were so excited.
而且你知道吗？我也想说，我带了很多家人和朋友去那个片场参观。你们总是最友善的人，总是花时间打招呼和拍照。我真的很感激这一点。我想让你知道。哦，谢谢。那太好了。当人们穿着靴子出来时，我们很兴奋。我们之前和我们的听众分享过。我们不在什么豪华的大片场，你会遇到其他人。基本上只是我们和一个火车站附近的仓库。是的，我们会说，哦天哪，我们从未见过或遇到过的人。就像，你知道，我觉得我们就像一只小狗，一个新人进了屋子，你只是太兴奋了。
Yeah, you were giddy. Well, it was always really fun. So we know how you and Steve met and that you were at Second City together. What was it like acting with him on the office being his scene partner? Yeah. So that was, well, it was very fun. But it was nerve wracking, you know, because even, you know, because this is your established show. He's so good. I was just trying to maintain, you know what I mean? Like I just didn't want to screw up royally. That was my mindset. So if you see that character, it's very sketch, she's pretty subdued. Yeah, she's very, she's the straight man, right? Yeah. And Jenna and I were talking about, there are a few looks that Carol gives Michael throughout these seven episodes
是的，你很轻浮。好吧，这总是很有趣。所以我们知道你和史蒂夫是怎么认识的，你们在第二城一起工作。在《办公室》里和他演对手戏是什么感觉？是的，所以那是，嗯，非常有趣。但让人紧张，你知道，因为即使，你知道，因为这是你们已经建立的节目。他太棒了。我只是试图保持，你知道我的意思吗？就像我只是不想彻底搞砸。那是我的心态。所以如果你看到那个角色，她非常素描，她相当克制。是的，她非常，她是直男，对吧？是的。而且珍娜和我一直在谈论，卡罗尔在这些七集里给迈克尔的几个眼神
that are so priceless. They're so honest because he'll say the most ridiculous things to you. I was telling Jenna and Michael's birthday when he sees you at the ice skating rink and he's like, you sell ice skating rinks and you're like, no, I'm not a real estate all the time. You know what I mean? Yeah. But you just played it so honest. It was so good. Yes. Well, I would have this experience, particularly with Brian Baumgartner when he was playing Kevin. I would find Kevin, and especially his attitude toward Pam, so off-putting. But I love Brian Baumgartner, he and I are very close friends, but Kevin would just irritate me. And I'm like curious, what was it like for you as Nancy, who loves Steve, having to then relate to him as Michael Scott?
是如此无价。它们是如此诚实，因为他会对你说最荒谬的话。我告诉珍娜，在迈克尔的生日那天，当他在溜冰场看到你时，他说，你卖溜冰场，而你说，不，我不是一直做房地产。你知道我的意思吗？是的。但你只是演得非常诚实。这太好了。是的。嗯，我会有这种经历，特别是和布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳演凯文的时候。我会发现凯文，尤其是他对帕姆的态度，非常令人反感。但我爱布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳，他和我是非常亲密的朋友，但凯文总是激怒我。我很好奇，作为爱史蒂夫的南希，不得不以迈克尔·斯科特的身份与他相处，感觉如何？
Was it so weird to like even see him as this other character and then you're relating with him? I don't know. Yeah, it was, it was weird because I mean, I had to also be somebody who was attracted to him enough to date him. So I was thinking like, what, how bad was my marriage that I thought this was a good guy to date? Yeah, what happened to Carol? I don't know. All I can think is her husband had to be the worst person on earth. And then she, you know, she met Michael at the, they were at the rink and she sees him with kids, right? Like relating. So I think that sort of, you know, warmed her heart a little bit. And maybe she had a really neglectful husband who didn't even like spend any time with her kids. There had to be something there because otherwise, I mean,
看到他作为这个角色，然后你又和他相处，是不是很奇怪？我不知道。是的，这很奇怪，因为我的意思是，我也必须是一个被他吸引到足以和他约会的人。所以我当时想，我的婚姻有多糟糕，以至于我认为这是一个约会的好男人？是的，卡罗尔怎么了？我不知道。我唯一能想到的是她的丈夫一定是地球上最糟糕的人。然后她，你知道，她在溜冰场遇到了迈克尔，她看到他和孩子们在一起，对吧？就像相处。所以我认为这多少，你知道，温暖了她的心。也许她有一个非常忽视她的丈夫，甚至不花时间陪她的孩子。一定有什么原因，否则，我的意思是，
definitely he, he was a quirky, quirky person that you wonder why she would date him. Well, you know, the year's post divorce can sometimes be a slippery slope as you regroup your life. Yeah, I mean, at Diwali, when you walk in in the cheerleading outfit, oh my God, because he told me it was a costume party, right? Yes, yes. And he could take his head off and then he was just in a suit. And then while you're in this outfit, which I'm sure you do not want highlighted, he takes the microphone and proposes to you in front of a huge crowd of people. Yes. Amazing. Do you have a favorite episode or a favorite scene that you did? You know, I have to say they were all so much fun, like for very different reasons. Diwali was
绝对地，他是一个古怪、古怪的人，你会想为什么她会和他约会。嗯，你知道，离婚后的几年有时会是一条滑坡，当你重新整理生活时。是的，我的意思是，在排灯节，当你穿着啦啦队服装走进来时，哦天哪，因为他告诉我这是一个化装舞会，对吧？是的，是的。然后他可以脱下头套，然后他只是穿着西装。然后当你穿着这套衣服时，我相信你不想被强调，他拿起麦克风在一大群人面前向你求婚。是的。太棒了。你有什么最喜欢的剧集或最喜欢的场景吗？你知道，我不得不说它们都非常有趣，因为非常不同的原因。排灯节是
so much fun to shoot because they had to teach me how to dance, you know? Or I had to be dancing. And I remember it was Mindy's parents who played her parents on that. Yes. And they were the sweetest people. So that was so great. I loved, I think Benihana Christmas was... The Christmas card. Yeah, the Christmas card. But I think that was Harold Ramis directed that. It was, yeah. So that was, I mean, he was like one of my idols and just the nicest guy too. So, you know, I love that one. I loved the last one, Jenna, when I think when we sold your house, I sold your house. And the couple I had to shoot with all day. I mean, we just, we were standing there for the entire day just laughing. I don't know. I can't even pick one. It was so much fun. Well, I personally love Casino
拍摄起来非常有趣，因为他们不得不教我如何跳舞，你知道吗？或者我不得不跳舞。我记得是明迪的父母在上面扮演她的父母。是的。他们是最可爱的人。所以那太棒了。我喜欢，我想《本尼哈纳圣诞节》是……圣诞贺卡。是的，圣诞贺卡。但我认为那是哈罗德·雷米斯执导的。是的，是的。所以那是，我的意思是，他就像我的偶像之一，也是最友善的人。所以，你知道，我喜欢那一个。我喜欢最后一个，珍娜，我想当我们卖掉你的房子时，我卖掉了你的房子。还有那对夫妇我不得不整天和他们一起拍摄。我的意思是，我们只是，我们整天站在那里只是笑。我不知道。我甚至选不出一个。这太有趣了。好吧，我个人喜欢《赌场
Night, the scene between you and Malora. Oh, at the bar with Jan and Carol at the bar is so good. Steve wrote that one, Casino Night. He did. I mean, along with everybody else, of course. All the other writers, of course. Yeah. Oh, we have a question for you. This is really random. We both, in our hearts, hope that you still have the Christmas card where Michael photoshopped his face over your ex husband. Oh my God. I wish I had that, because I would make it into an ornament for my tree. Yeah. That is such a great idea. We will do it for you. We are going to do that. Yes, as a thank you guest for being on Office Ladies, you will be getting that Christmas ornament as an ornament. I would love that, because I remember, I do remember this very
之夜》，你和马洛拉之间的场景。哦，在酒吧里，简和卡罗尔在酒吧里太棒了。史蒂夫写了那一集，《赌场之夜》。他确实写了。我的意思是，当然还有其他人。当然还有所有其他编剧。是的。哦，我们有一个问题要问你。这真的很随机。我们俩，在我们的心中，希望你仍然有那张圣诞贺卡，迈克尔把他的脸P在了你前夫的脸上。哦，天哪。我真希望我有那个，因为我会把它做成我树上的装饰品。是的。那真是个好主意。我们会为你做的。我们要那样做。是的，作为感谢嘉宾来到《办公室女士》，你将得到那个圣诞装饰品作为装饰。我会喜欢的，因为我记得，我确实记得这个非常
distinctly when I'm kind of confronting him about doing that. And I'm like, that's just so weird. Like, it's just so weird that you did that. That's it. She can't, she's done, and he's like, you walk out that door, it's over, and you say, I know. I know. And then I think that's when he takes Jan on vacation, right? Doesn't he take her to? Yes, to Jamaica. Yeah. Well, you played Carol Stills in seven episodes of The Office. It ranged from season two all the way to the finale. Do you ever get recognized when you're out and about? Do people call you Carol? When I'm alone? Not very often, but when I'm with Steve. Oh my goodness. It's always like every day I come across. I was today, years old, when I realized Steve was
清楚，当我有点质问他这样做时。我说，这太奇怪了。就像，你这样做太奇怪了。就是这样。她不能，她受够了，他说，你走出那扇门，一切就结束了，你说，我知道。我知道。然后我想那就是他带简去度假的时候，对吧？他没带她去吗？是的，去牙买加。是的。好吧，你在《办公室》的七集里扮演了卡罗尔·斯蒂尔斯。范围从第二季一直到大结局。你出门在外时会被认出来吗？人们叫你卡罗尔吗？当我一个人的时候？不经常，但当我和史蒂夫在一起时。哦，天哪。总是像每天我都会遇到。我今天，几岁了，当我意识到史蒂夫是
married to Carol, the real estate agent. So, or like if somebody recognizes Steve, and then, you know, I've certainly, I take a lot of pictures in my life of people with Steve, and then they'll hand me the camera and they'll say, I know who you are too. Oh, thanks. Thanks so much. Nancy, you and my husband need to have drinks sometimes, because you know, he was the lactation consultant. Clark. Clark in an episode of The Office, and it happens to him same thing all the time. I was today, years old, when I realized Jenna Fisher married her lactation consultant. Yes. Well, all my husband gets is, you're not Dwight. Well, it's just crazy that the show still is in the zeitgeist. I mean, we probably could have
嫁给了卡罗尔，那位房地产经纪人。所以，或者如果有人认出史蒂夫，然后，你知道，我当然，我一生中拍了很多人们和史蒂夫的照片，然后他们会把相机递给我，他们会说，我也知道你是谁。哦，谢谢。太感谢了。南希，你和我丈夫有时需要喝一杯，因为你知道，他是哺乳顾问。克拉克。克拉克在《办公室》的一集里，同样的事情总是发生在他身上。我今天，几岁了，当我意识到珍娜·费舍嫁给了她的哺乳顾问。是的。好吧，我丈夫得到的只是，你不是德怀特。好吧，这部剧仍然在时代精神中真是太疯狂了。我的意思是，我们可能永远无法
never imagined that. No. That all these years later, you'd still be out to dinner and people would be like, Carol. I know. Who would have thought that? And then, you know, we were talking to this man last week, and he was with his third grade son. He was like, and he's just started watching it. I'm like, I don't think he was born when it went off the air. And then he's watched like, it's, it's insane, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah, it really is. My husband was like, And you guys are now like an, I love Lucy. Yeah. Generations are going to watch this show. I know. And what a, what an amazing thing though. Huh? Yeah. I mean, when, when you think about it, like that is just mind blowing. Yeah. It's just, it's very fortunate. What just amazing.
想象。不。这么多年过去了，你还会出去吃晚饭，人们会说，卡罗尔。我知道。谁会想到呢？然后，你知道，我们上周和这个人谈话，他和他的三年级儿子在一起。他说，他刚开始看。我说，我不认为他在节目停播时出生。然后他看了像，这，这太疯狂了，不是吗？是的。是的，确实如此。我丈夫说，你们现在就像《我爱露西》。是的。几代人都会看这部剧。我知道。而且这是一件多么了不起的事情啊，嗯？是的。我的意思是，当你想到它时，那真是令人震惊。是的。这真是太幸运了。真是太神奇了。
It was really like a lightning in a bottle kind of show, wasn't it? Like just every element came together so beautifully. Yeah. Sort of that once in a lifetime. Well, hopefully you'll have more. I don't know. I think it'll be very hard to do another show. We've both worked on other shows, and you're right. It was lightning in a bottle. We'll all go on to do other things, but this was a magical time for sure. It really was. Yeah. Steve feels the same way for sure. And that's why there's third graders with, you know, Dunder Mifflin shirts on. That's right. Well, I have one last question for you. We always ask everyone, if they took anything from the set before they left the show, now I don't know collectively if you and Steve have something
这真的就像一个瓶子里的闪电，不是吗？就像每一个元素都结合得如此美妙。是的。那种千载难逢的感觉。好吧，希望你会有更多。我不知道。我认为再拍一部剧会非常困难。我们都参与过其他剧，你是对的。那是瓶子里的闪电。我们都会继续做其他事情，但这绝对是一个神奇的时刻。确实如此。是的。史蒂夫肯定也有同样的感觉。这就是为什么有穿着邓德·米夫林衬衫的三年级学生。没错。好吧，我最后一个问题要问你。我们总是问每个人，他们在离开剧组之前是否从片场拿走了什么，现在我不知道你和史蒂夫是否集体有什么
from the set. I mean, Jen and I, obviously we've shared this, we took a lot of things. I so want you to say that you took like the for sale sign from the lawn of the finale, but I'm sure that would be a very odd thing if you're just pulling it out of the ground. Be like, I'm taking this. Just throwing it in my car. You know what? No. I don't think Steve took one thing. Wow. We're going to follow up. Guess what? You're going to have, you're going to have a Christmas ornament of that postcard. That'll be your little nod. Yeah. No, I don't think he took anything. I remember, do you remember his last day? I mean, I just remember crying a lot.
从片场拿走。我的意思是，珍娜和我，显然我们分享过，我们拿了很多东西。我真希望你说你拿走了大结局草坪上的待售标志，但我敢肯定，如果你只是把它从地里拔出来，那会是一件非常奇怪的事情。就像，我拿走这个。只是把它扔进我的车里。你知道吗？不。我不认为史蒂夫拿走了一样东西。哇。我们要跟进。猜猜怎么着？你会有，你会有那张明信片的圣诞装饰品。那将是你的小点头。是的。不，我不认为他拿走了任何东西。我记得，你记得他最后一天吗？我的意思是，我只记得哭了很多。
Yeah. The big party and then they made him a huge coffee cup cake that said world's best boss. I do remember that. And then you guys all signed a hockey jersey for him. Like, so we have all that stuff. You know, we have that framed and we have that up, but not the coffee cup cake. Yeah. But so we have stuff like that, but no, he never took like, you know, his anything. Wow. I would think he would have like his Dundee from his desk or something. I don't know. You know what? He's too classy. He's too classy, Jenna. He didn't rob the set on his way out like the rest of us Hurligans for like, is that nailed down? It's going with me. Well, maybe he thought, he wasn't, he probably wasn't sure if like anybody was going to need it again because, you know.
是的。盛大的派对，然后他们为他做了一个巨大的咖啡杯蛋糕，上面写着“世界最佳老板”。我确实记得那个。然后你们都为他签了一件曲棍球衫。所以，我们有所有那些东西。你知道，我们把它装裱起来，我们把它挂起来，但不是咖啡杯蛋糕。是的。但所以我们有像那样的东西，但没有，他从来没有拿走像，你知道，他的任何东西。哇。我以为他会拿走他桌上的邓迪奖杯什么的。我不知道。你知道吗？他太有格调了。他太有格调了，珍娜。他没有像我们这些捣蛋鬼一样在离开时抢劫片场，比如，那个钉住了吗？它要跟我走。好吧，也许他想，他可能不确定是否有人会再次需要它，因为，你知道。
Well, that's true, right? Because the show kept going. Yeah. So you kind of couldn't. Could you imagine? We're like, where'd the Dundee Mifflin sign go? Steve, no one's seen it. Steve left. Where did the desk go in Michael's office? He stole everything. Oh, Nancy, thank you so much for coming on and talking with us. You were such a big part of the show, both on camera and behind the scenes. We just have the best memories of you coming to set either with your family or as Carol. This was so great. Thanks, you guys. I too have the best memories. That was, that show was a joy and everybody involved with it was just incredible. And it was a real privilege to be on that show and to know you
好吧，那是真的，对吧？因为节目还在继续。是的。所以你有点不能。你能想象吗？我们就像，邓德·米夫林标志去哪了？史蒂夫，没人见过它。史蒂夫走了。迈克尔办公室里的桌子去哪了？他偷了一切。哦，南希，非常感谢你来和我们交谈。你是这部剧的重要组成部分，无论是在镜头前还是在幕后。我们对你带着家人或以卡罗尔的身份来到片场有着最好的回忆。这太棒了。谢谢你们。我也拥有最好的回忆。那，那部剧是一种快乐，参与其中的每个人都令人难以置信。能参加那部剧并认识你们真是一种荣幸
guys. We feel the same way. You know, BJ Novak said something to me recently. He was like, Angela, it's office family forever. For family forever. It's true. It's like it's so true. It's true. We love you. We love you. I love you too. I just kind of need Nancy to be another office ladies and hang out with us all the time. I agree. Can we make that happen? How much texting to her is too much? I feel like we blew up her phone lately. Well, let's get into this episode. Let's do that, lady. Is anyone else out there watching the DVDs? Anyone? Let me know, because did you notice this disk is full of so many ads? It is. You have to sit through all these commercials
伙计们。我们也有同样的感觉。你知道，BJ·诺瓦克最近对我说了些什么。他说，安吉拉，这是永远的办公室家庭。永远的家庭。这是真的。这太真实了。这是真的。我们爱你。我们爱你。我也爱你。我只是有点需要南希成为另一个办公室女士，一直和我们在一起。我同意。我们能实现吗？给她发多少短信才算太多？我觉得我们最近炸了她的手机。好吧，让我们进入这一集。让我们这样做，女士。还有人在看DVD吗？有人吗？让我知道，因为你注意到这张光盘里有很多广告吗？确实。你必须看完所有这些商业广告
for other things done by Universal Studios. And I'm just like, I can quote the big Lebowski to you now. The big Lebowski the movie was being promoted on the office DVD. Yes, especially on this one. Especially on this disk for season seven. You guys know, you folks out there watching it, it's like Parks and Rec and then all of a sudden the big Lebowski. That's crazy. Anyway, just saying a lot of ads on this one. Let's talk about this cold open because Dwight has gone up to some kind of hardware store where there's day laborers, they're looking for a job, and he's pulled up and he's asking someone to come with him to work. Yes, but no one will go. And we find out why. An older worker explains that no one goes with this man. This man being Dwight.
为环球影业做的其他事情。我只是觉得，我现在可以给你引用《大人物勒博斯基》。电影《大人物勒博斯基》正在《办公室》DVD上宣传。是的，特别是在这一张上。特别是在第七季的这张光盘上。你们知道，你们这些在看的人，就像《公园与游憩》，然后突然就是《大人物勒博斯基》。这太疯狂了。总之，只是说这一张上有很多广告。让我们谈谈这个冷开场，因为德怀特去了一家五金店，那里有日薪工，他们在找工作，他开车停下来，要求某人跟他一起去工作。是的，但没人会去。我们发现了原因。一位年长的工人解释说，没有人跟这个人走。这个人就是德怀特。
That's right. Because when they go with him, they never come back. Yeah. It's a mystery. So they're not going with him anymore. No. The man who's explaining all this to us in Spanish is Abraham Chavez and the boy who is interpreting is Oscar Blanco. Neither of them have been on Monk or House. Oh, you don't get to do your house pun. I don't. Guests are in the house. I mean, spoiler alert, I'm not going to get to do it all episode. I'm bummed, but it's okay. Well, in this cold open, we are going to meet Nate. He approaches Dwight's car. They speak terrible Spanish to one another. Yes. And Dwight is like, all right, you can work for me today. Hop in. Yeah. He's going to bring him to our parking lot where he asks him to, I guess, get a hornet's nest
没错。因为当他们跟他走时，他们就再也没回来。是的。这是一个谜。所以他们不再跟他走了。不。用西班牙语向我们解释这一切的人是亚伯拉罕·查韦斯，翻译的男孩是奥斯卡·布兰科。他们都没有参加过《神探阿蒙》或《豪斯医生》。哦，你没能做你的豪斯医生双关语。我没有。客人在屋里。我的意思是，剧透警告，我整集都做不到。我很沮丧，但没关系。好吧，在这个冷开场中，我们将见到内特。他走近德怀特的车。他们用糟糕的西班牙语交谈。是的。德怀特说，好吧，你今天可以为我工作。跳上来。是的。他要带他去我们的停车场，在那里他让他，我想，把一个黄蜂窝
out of a tree. He's going to give him a few ways to do that. Blowtorch, bow and arrow, bat. There's a few options. Yeah. It's kind of a test. He ultimately chooses the bat. Yeah. Bad idea. The whole bullpen has gathered around to watch this. They're very invested, worried. There's highs, there's lows. It's a really high energy moment for the group. And Randy shared with us that at a minute, seven seconds, when you see that establishing shot of Nate in the parking lot, all of those shots were from Greg Daniel's office window. That's right. Yeah. But the cast was actually in our conference room set. And I remember when we were shooting that, that our first AD was calling out the Nate action. We couldn't actually see him. We were looking at nothing. We were looking at a
从树上弄下来。他要给他几种方法来做。喷灯，弓箭，球棒。有几个选择。是的。这算是一种测试。他最终选择了球棒。是的。坏主意。整个牛棚都聚集在一起观看这个。他们非常投入，担心。有高潮，有低谷。这对团队来说是一个非常高能量的时刻。兰迪和我们分享说，在七秒钟时，当你看到内特在停车场的那个建立镜头时，所有这些镜头都来自格雷格·丹尼尔斯的办公室窗户。没错。是的。但演员实际上是在我们的会议室片场。我记得当我们拍摄那个时，我们的第一助理导演在喊内特的动作。我们实际上看不到他。我们什么也没看。我们看着一个
scrim, just a painted backdrop. And we were pretending to react to all the different things they were saying. I think it went together very well. I think we sold it. We really did. We sold someone in the wings yelling, okay, blowtorch. Now a bat. Randy also shared that Phil Shea had three fake hornet's nests made out of paper mache. He got them from the hand prop room prop house. Try saying that fast. Hand prop room prop house. Do it again. Hand prop room prop house, hand prop room prop house, hand prop. Oh my God, you're, you're like a tongue twister genius. Just that one. I don't, don't give me any more. Can you say I'm a sheep slitter, I slit sheep. I'm a slickest sheep slitter to ever slit a sheep. I'm a, I don't, I'm a what? Sheep slitter. I'm a
薄纱，只是一个彩绘背景。我们假装对他们说的所有不同事情做出反应。我认为它结合得很好。我认为我们卖掉了它。我们真的卖掉了有人在侧翼大喊，好吧，喷灯。现在是球棒。兰迪还分享说，菲尔·谢有三个用纸浆做的假黄蜂窝。他从手道具室道具屋拿到的。试着快点说那个。手道具室道具屋。再做一次。手道具室道具屋，手道具室道具屋，手道具。哦，天哪，你，你是个绕口令天才。就那一个。我不要，不要再给我了。你能说我是个剪羊毛的人，我剪羊毛。我是有史以来最滑的剪羊毛人。我是个，我不是个什么？剪羊毛的人。我是个
sheep slitter. I slit sheep. I slit sheep. I'm the best sheep. I'm the slickest. Oh, I'm the slickest sheep slitter that ever slit sheep. Sheep. Sheets. Sheep. It's not easy. Why am I slitting sheep? I don't know. It's so violent. I don't know. One of my, can we just go back to Peter Piper? One of my, one of my like old relatives in Texas taught me that one night. I was like a little kid going like, I'm a sheep slitter. I slit sheep. When you did your like acting training, did you have to do those? Did you do those to like warm up your mouth? No, I didn't. I just showed up to work. Oh my gosh. When I did that play in New York, me and Leslie Bibb, that's who did the play with me. We would get to the theater early and we would do all of these vocal exercises. You must have
剪羊毛的人。我剪羊毛。我剪羊毛。我是最好的羊。我是最滑的。哦，我是有史以来剪羊毛最滑的人。羊。床单。羊。这不容易。为什么我在剪羊毛？我不知道。这太暴力了。我不知道。我的一位，我们能回到彼得·派珀吗？我的一位，我的一位像德克萨斯的老亲戚有一天晚上教我那个。我像个小孩子一样说，我是个剪羊毛的人。我剪羊毛。当你做你的表演训练时，你必须做那些吗？你做那些来像热身你的嘴吗？不，我没有。我只是去上班。哦，天哪。当我在纽约演那部戏时，我和莱斯利·比布，就是和我一起演那部戏的人。我们会早点到剧院，我们会做所有这些发声练习。你一定
been so happy. We, oh my God. Leslie Bibb was such an acting nerd. She had her vocal coach come in and lead the cast in vocal exercises. And doing things like mouth thing for projection in the theater. I am too much of a smart ass to make it through that class. I took it 100% seriously. I know you did. I know you did. But that's why I would like you, Angela, because you need someone who's a little bit of a smart ass. You can't take it too seriously. Every once in a while, you need someone to check you. You do. All of the hornets were fake, you guys. There were no real hornets and they were added in post-production by Encore VFX. I once thought I had a swarm of bees. I related to Nate in this moment. I was like terrified. I was like, what are we doing?
很高兴。我们，哦天哪。莱斯利·比布真是个表演书呆子。她让她的声乐教练进来带领演员进行发声练习。并做一些像在剧院里投射的嘴部动作。我太聪明了，无法通过那门课。我100%认真对待它。我知道你做了。我知道你做了。但这就是为什么我喜欢你，安吉拉，因为你需要一个有点聪明的人。你不能太认真。偶尔，你需要有人检查你。你需要。所有的黄蜂都是假的，伙计们。没有真正的黄蜂，它们是由Encore VFX在后期制作中添加的。我曾经以为我有一群蜜蜂。我在这一刻和内特产生了共鸣。我当时很害怕。我说，我们在做什么？
A swarm of bees, what? You had a swarm of bees following you? Not following me. Okay, so I'm in my house and I keep hearing a buzzing. And I'm like, what is this buzzing? And I keep hearing it and hearing it. And it's always on this one wall side. And I'm like, what is this? And then in addition to the buzzing, I started hearing like this, like tink, tink, tink, tink, tink. And I'm like, what is the buzzing and the tinking? I'm crawling around the house looking for this. And then I realize I look in the fireplace. There's all of these bees in the fireplace, and they're hitting the glass doors of the fireplace. What? And there's like a lot of them. They had come down your chimney? Yes. So I was like, well, crap, what do you do?
一群蜜蜂，什么？你有一群蜜蜂跟着你？不是跟着我。好吧，所以我在我的房子里，我一直听到嗡嗡声。我说，这是什么嗡嗡声？我一直听到它，听到它。它总是在这一面墙上。我说，这是什么？然后除了嗡嗡声，我开始听到像这个，像叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。我说，什么是嗡嗡声和叮叮声？我在房子里爬来爬去寻找这个。然后我意识到我看了看壁炉。壁炉里有所有的蜜蜂，它们在撞击壁炉的玻璃门。什么？而且有很多。它们从你的烟囱下来了？是的。所以我当时想，好吧，该死，你做什么？
A friend of mine referred me to a beekeeper removal and relocation company. Wait, I love it. Yes. They relocate them. Yes. They don't exterminate. No, no, no. Because you know we need the bees. No. As my mom says, we bless them and move them along. That's right. That's right. So they show up and they quickly tell me I don't have a swarm of bees that I have scouting bees. Do you know what scouting bees are? No. They're so cool. Okay, scouting bees are female worker bees. And their primary task is to find and locate a new place for the colony to build a hive. Oh. So they go out looking, they go really far. And it usually happens because the hive has gotten overcrowded. And once the scouting bees have found a suitable
我的一个朋友把我介绍给了一家养蜂人清除和搬迁公司。等等，我喜欢它。是的。他们搬迁它们。是的。他们不消灭。不，不，不。因为你知道我们需要蜜蜂。不。正如我妈妈所说，我们祝福它们并让它们继续前进。没错。没错。所以他们出现了，他们很快告诉我我没有一群蜜蜂，我有侦察蜂。你知道什么是侦察蜂吗？不。它们太酷了。好吧，侦察蜂是雌性工蜂。它们的主要任务是寻找和定位一个新的地方让蜂群筑巢。哦。所以它们出去寻找，它们走得很远。而且通常发生这种情况是因为蜂巢已经过度拥挤了。一旦侦察蜂找到了一个合适的
location, they'll go back to the hive and they'll perform a dance, which is communicated to the rest of the hive. The dance gives information on the location that the scout has found. So basically, the scouts were like, we found a place, guys. And it's Angela's chimney. Okay. I don't know where to begin. First of all, I'm hanging on every word. I need to see a documentary of this bee dance. But my other thought is like they did a terrible job. They did a terrible job if they scouted your chimney as a new place to live. They don't know we're ever going to light it up. For them, it's like a little cozy spot. I guess. And the thing I love is that the scouting bees, they go, they send out the information,
位置，它们会回到蜂巢并表演一种舞蹈，这会传达给蜂巢的其他部分。舞蹈提供了侦察员发现的位置的信息。所以基本上，侦察员就像，伙计们，我们找到了一个地方。而且是安吉拉的烟囱。好吧。我不知道从哪里开始。首先，我听得入迷。我需要看一部关于这种蜜蜂舞蹈的纪录片。但我另一个想法是，它们做得太糟糕了。如果它们侦察你的烟囱作为新的居住地，它们做得太糟糕了。它们不知道我们什么时候会点燃它。对它们来说，这就像一个舒适的小地方。我想。而且我喜欢的是，侦察蜂，它们去，它们发出信息，
and then other scouting bees come. And if they all agree that the location is a good one, they'll go back to the hive and get the entire colony to come. I'm fascinated by scouting bees, you guys. Well, what happens if the company comes and then they relocate the scouting bees, and the scouting bees never come back and dance for the rest of the people? The rest of the bee friends? I've like anthropomorphized. What is that? You know what it is? Yeah. They're a company. They're people now. They're not scouting bees. They're a whole industry. Yeah. So they got the scouting bees to leave. Like scouting bees, this is not a nice place. And then they told me I needed to fix the top of my fireplace,
然后其他侦察蜂来了。如果它们都同意这个位置是一个好位置，它们会回到蜂巢并让整个蜂群过来。我被侦察蜂迷住了，伙计们。好吧，如果公司来了，然后他们搬走了侦察蜂，而侦察蜂再也没有回来为其他人跳舞会发生什么？剩下的蜜蜂朋友？我把它们拟人化了。那是什么？你知道那是什么吗？是的。它们是一家公司。它们现在是人了。它们不是侦察蜂。它们是一个完整的行业。是的。所以他们让侦察蜂离开了。就像侦察蜂，这不是一个好地方。然后他们告诉我我需要修理壁炉的顶部，
that there's like this little special mesh thing you can get so they don't come in. So I did that. Can you imagine if the scouting bees, they went back, they did the dance. They're like, we found a new place. And then more came and they're like, what are you talking about? We can't even get in. Yeah. And then they all had to go back. And then the queen was like to the one scouting bee like, what the hell, man? I know. And then that first scouting group is just, they're humiliated. They never live it down. They never live it down. Remember that time you went to that chimney? Yeah. And we all went. We all packed up. We went to look at the chimney. Way to go. We didn't even get in. Nice job. We're putting you back on pollen.
有一种小小的特殊网状物你可以得到，这样它们就不会进来。所以我做了。你能想象如果侦察蜂，它们回去了，它们跳了舞。它们就像，我们找到了一个新地方。然后更多的人来了，它们就像，你在说什么？我们甚至进不去。是的。然后它们都不得不回去。然后女王就像对那只侦察蜂说，这到底是怎么回事，伙计？我知道。然后那第一组侦察员只是，它们被羞辱了。它们永远无法摆脱它。它们永远无法摆脱它。还记得你上次去那个烟囱吗？是的。我们都去了。我们都收拾好了。我们去看了烟囱。干得好。我们甚至没进去。干得漂亮。我们让你回去采花粉。
You don't get to scout anymore. There's a lot of videos about bees out there, you guys. They're fascinating. I'm just going to tell you, go watch a few. I love bees. Well, we got a fan mail flurry over this cold open. Valerie W from Colorado and Megan W from Farmville, North Carolina and many others all said, I have to know more about Nate. He's one of my all time favorite recurring characters. What was his audition process like? How did you find him? Well, this is one of my favorite office stories of all time, how we found Nate. I love it so much. And I became such good friends with Nate that I actually interviewed him for my book, The Actor's Life, a Survival Guide, because his story of how he
你不能再侦察了。外面有很多关于蜜蜂的视频，伙计们。它们很迷人。我只是要告诉你，去看几个。我爱蜜蜂。好吧，我们在这个冷开场上收到了一阵粉丝邮件。来自科罗拉多州的瓦莱丽·W和北卡罗来纳州法姆维尔的梅根·W以及许多其他人都在说，我必须更多地了解内特。他是我有史以来最喜欢的常驻角色之一。他的试镜过程是什么样的？你是怎么找到他的？好吧，这是我最喜欢的《办公室》故事之一，我们是如何找到内特的。我太喜欢它了。而且我成了内特的好朋友，以至于我实际上采访了他，为了我的书，《演员的生活，生存指南》，因为他如何
got on the office is all based on him making up his own work, his own character all the way back in his hometown. Nate was played by Mark Brooks and the writers of the office discovered Mark from a series of prank videos that he did that were uploaded to YouTube. He didn't even upload them to YouTube. Other people did. Here's what he did. He created a character called Kastros, who was a yo-yo expert who goes into schools. Yes, and he does yo-yo shows. Yeah. This was the premise. He never actually did this, but his premise was that he was a yo-yo expert who did yo-yo tricks for elementary kids while also teaching them about environmentalism. And he would book himself on local news stations as a yo-yo expert. I'm sorry. I'm laughing because I'm
进入《办公室》的故事完全基于他自己编造工作，他自己的角色，一直回到他的家乡。内特由马克·布鲁克斯扮演，《办公室》的编剧从他上传到YouTube的一系列恶作剧视频中发现了马克。他甚至没有把它们上传到YouTube。其他人做了。这是他做的。他创造了一个叫卡斯特罗斯的角色，他是一个去学校的溜溜球专家。是的，他做溜溜球表演。是的。这就是前提。他从来没有真正做过这个，但他的前提是他是一个溜溜球专家，为小学生表演溜溜球技巧，同时教他们关于环保主义的知识。他会把自己预订在当地新闻台作为溜溜球专家。对不起。我在笑，因为我
remembering these videos and they are so funny. They are so brilliant because once he gets on the news show, he slowly starts to break down and then can't do any tricks at all. I have a clip. It's so good. We can listen. We have a yo-yo champion on hometown this morning today. Right. Kastros, good morning. Thanks for coming on. Thank you. How are you? Good. Can you go around of schools with yo-yos and show demonstrations and you have a goal behind all this? Yeah. I go around. I've been teaching kids about the environment. Actually, I've only been in one school so far and I'll be honest. I didn't go so hot. In fact, it was literally a major disaster. Oh, no. Because basically, the kids didn't like my stories and it's no surprise because they were running around
记得这些视频，它们太搞笑了。它们太聪明了，因为一旦他上了新闻节目，他慢慢开始崩溃，然后根本做不出任何技巧。我有一个片段。太好了。我们可以听听。我们今天在《家乡早晨》有一位溜溜球冠军。对。卡斯特罗斯，早上好。谢谢你来。谢谢。你好吗？好。你带着溜溜球去学校做演示，你在这背后有一个目标？是的。我到处走。我一直在教孩子们关于环境的知识。实际上，我到目前为止只去过一所学校，老实说。我做得不太好。事实上，这简直是一场大灾难。哦，不。因为基本上，孩子们不喜欢我的故事，这并不奇怪，因为他们一直在跑来跑去
all the time. And I'm sorry. I think there's something to be said about how kids are brought up these days. And I come from a home that believed in spanking. And so when I was being bad, you know, daddy would get a switch or a belt and I would get it and I would get it good. And I am literally terrified, you know, to this day. Well, hopefully you can, you know, try another school. I mean, it was your first time. So maybe you can see for the next time. But basically, you go around and you talk about nature. I mean, going green, the whole going green event. Is that basically the whole point behind your message, which you're going to try to spread? Well, yeah. And but I kind of have breaking news. I am this may literally be the last time you see me in this shirt.
一直。对不起。我认为关于孩子们这些天是如何长大的，有一些话要说。我来自一个相信体罚的家庭。所以当我表现不好时，你知道，爸爸会拿一根棍子或皮带，我会得到它，我会得到它。而且我简直吓坏了，你知道，直到今天。好吧，希望你能，你知道，尝试另一所学校。我的意思是，这是你第一次。所以也许你可以为下一次看看。但基本上，你到处走，谈论自然。我的意思是，绿色环保，整个绿色环保活动。这基本上是你想要传播的信息背后的全部重点吗？好吧，是的。而且但我有一种突发新闻。我，这可能是你最后一次看到我穿这件衬衫。
They are going in a different direction. And it's a direction without me. And am I angry about this guy? Yes, I am. Well, let's let's how about you show us some yo-yo demonstrations. I mean, you are the yo-yo champ. You brought a yo-yo with you, right? I asked actually last night what I did was I came up with one named after the station. Oh, really? Yes. So what is called the KQTV? KQTV. KQTV. Or two. KQ2. There you go. Yeah. We go by two different things. We'll go ahead and show the KQ2 yo-yo move. Okay, so here's it's longer. Here's what happens. He starts by doing just a simple up and down move. Yeah. And he's fine. He does it. But then he tries to do his special move and he hits himself in the face with the yo-yo. Like hard. He can clearly do no tricks. The anchors
他们正朝着不同的方向发展。这是一个没有我的方向。我对此生气吗？是的，我是。好吧，让我们，让我们展示一些溜溜球演示怎么样。我的意思是，你是溜溜球冠军。你带了一个溜溜球，对吧？我实际上昨晚做的是我想出了一个以车站命名的。哦，真的吗？是的。所以它叫KQTV？KQTV。KQTV。或者二。KQ2。给你。是的。我们有两种不同的东西。我们继续展示KQ2溜溜球动作。好吧，所以这里它更长。发生了什么。他开始只是做一个简单的上下动作。是的。而且他很好。他做了。但他试图做他的特殊动作，他用溜溜球打自己的脸。就像用力。他显然做不出任何技巧。主播
are then like flinching every time he attempts to do it because they're like, what is it's amazing. He did this several times. The writers saw these videos and they called him in for a meeting. They created this character for him. His story is really so amazing. We're definitely going to have him on the podcast. I don't even want to tell the whole story because I want him to tell it. Yeah, exactly. But check out these videos of Kay Stross. They're fantastic. Mark, we can't wait to have you on. The news anchor trying to pivot. I know. Like trying so hard. Well, maybe next time will be better. Yeah. Why don't you show us one of your tricks? Just amazing. Well, this episode is going to start with Michael arriving wearing a fake mustache. A giant fake mustache. Erin is
然后就像每次他尝试做时都在退缩，因为他们就像，这是什么，太神奇了。他做了好几次。编剧们看到了这些视频，他们叫他去开会。他们为他创造了这个角色。他的故事真的很神奇。我们一定要请他上播客。我甚至不想讲整个故事，因为我想让他自己讲。是的，完全正确。但看看这些卡斯特罗斯的视频。它们太棒了。马克，我们迫不及待地想让你来。新闻主播试图转移话题。我知道。就像努力尝试一样。好吧，也许下次会更好。是的。你为什么不给我们展示一个你的技巧？太神奇了。好吧，这一集将以迈克尔戴着假胡子到达开始。一个巨大的假胡子。艾琳是
so tickled by it. Yes. Yeah. She likes it. He then has a talking head where while he's doing the talking head, he's spinning his chair. I mean, everything he's saying is hilarious to me, but I could hear his chair go. And that just made me laugh. He says there's many reasons a man might wear a fake mustache to work. He's a fan of the outrageous. He loves to surprise. He also loves other things. Well, Michael goes to get some coffee and his giant mustache falls off into his mug, revealing something very large on his lip. Phyllis notices. People gasp. That's what I said in the shooting draft. I said, people gasp. I was like, that's kind of harsh. Michael says it's a big pimple and he says, you know what? Who cares? Avril Lavigne has pimples and she rocks harder
被它逗乐了。是的。是的。她喜欢它。然后他有一个访谈镜头，在访谈时，他一直在转动椅子。我的意思是，他说的每一句话对我来说都很搞笑，但我能听到他的椅子发出声音。这让我笑了。他说男人去上班戴假胡子有很多原因。他是个离谱行为的粉丝。他喜欢给人惊喜。他也喜欢其他事情。好吧，迈克尔去拿咖啡，他巨大的胡子掉进了杯子里，露出了嘴唇上非常大的东西。菲利斯注意到了。人们倒吸一口凉气。这就是我在拍摄草稿里写的。我说，人们倒吸一口凉气。我当时想，这有点刺耳。迈克尔说那是一个大痘痘，他说，你知道吗？谁在乎呢？艾薇儿·拉维尼也有痘痘，但她比任何人都酷。
than anyone else. Jenna, do you remember at this time Avril Lavigne had a proactive campaign? Lady, do I? I know why you remember because someone else was part of that campaign. It was Avril Lavigne, Katy Perry, and you. I know. It was me. That was so cool. Yeah. That was my first big campaign. So I feel like all of our writers knew that. I wondered when I saw it, if that's how that line made it in there. Do you have like photos from that? Do you have like a photo of you with a proactive box? You can find the commercial of me. You know, when you get asked about doing the proactive campaign, you have to have really used it. I really liked that. And I have really used it. I used it like all through college. And so I was like, yes. And you also have to send in photos of yourself
詹娜，你还记得当时艾薇儿·拉维尼有Proactiv的广告活动吗？女士，我怎么会不记得？我知道你为什么记得，因为还有别人也参与了那个活动。那是艾薇儿·拉维尼、凯蒂·佩里和你。我知道。是我。那太酷了。是的。那是我第一个大型广告活动。所以我感觉我们所有的编剧都知道这一点。我看到的时候就在想，那句台词是不是就是这么加进去的。你有当时的照片吗？你有你拿着Proactiv盒子的照片吗？你可以找到我的那个广告。你知道，当你被问到是否要参加Proactiv活动时，你必须真的用过它。我真的很喜欢它。而且我确实用过。我在大学期间一直都在用。所以我当时就说，好的。而且你还必须寄出你自己的照片
with like pimples. You have to like a before and after kind of thing. Yeah. And then they use those in your testimonial. Oh, I still want to see the commercial. So that was like, that was the whole thing. Sam is actively looking for the commercial. I see you, Sam. Oh my gosh, there it is. Yeah. You know, when you have acne, there's so much more time that you spend getting ready in the morning. The time of trying to cover up the cracky zit or the oozy zit. You know, that's 20 minutes that I don't have in the morning. When I'm using proactive, I don't have to worry about that stuff. And that's nice. You look so cute. Well, you know what's funny? They also make you write your own testimonial. So it makes sense to me that I wrote about how I don't have time for this.
比如长痘痘的照片。你得提供那种使用前后的对比照。是的。然后他们会把这些用在你的推荐语里。哦，我还是想看那个广告。所以这就是整个事情。山姆正在积极寻找那个广告。我看到你了，山姆。天哪，找到了。是的。你知道，当你长痘痘的时候，早上准备的时间会多很多。花时间去遮盖那个裂开的痘痘或者流脓的痘痘。你知道，那是我早上没有的20分钟。当我使用Proactiv时，我就不用担心那些事情了。那真好。你看上去真可爱。好吧，你知道什么很有趣吗？他们还让你写自己的推荐语。所以我写关于我没有时间处理这些的内容就很合理了。
Like that was my come from. I was like, you know what, I don't have time to cover this. That was that was my take. Well, you look adorable. Well, the group is not convinced that this is a pimple. No. And they have to start debating it. The word cancer is thrown out there. It sure is. Meredith is like, I know what it is. It's a cold sore. It's herpes. I have it. And everyone's like, this is so much information. Well, then they asked Michael, when was the last time he was tested for STDs? And he said, well, he had his last physical when he was 40. Jim is shocked. That's like 10 years ago, right? Michael is like, no, it's four years ago. And in the shooting draft, there was an extra Phyllis line. It's the same bit that Phyllis always has when Michael states his
就像那是我的出发点。我当时想，你知道吗，我没时间遮盖这个。那就是我的切入点。好吧，你看上去很可爱。好吧，大家并不相信这是一个痘痘。不。他们不得不开始争论。有人提到了癌症这个词。确实提到了。梅雷迪思说，我知道那是什么。那是唇疱疹。是疱疹。我有这个。大家都觉得，这信息量太大了。好吧，然后他们问迈克尔，他上次做性病检查是什么时候？他说，他上次体检是在他40岁的时候。吉姆很震惊。那是10年前的事了，对吧？迈克尔说，不，是4年前。在拍摄草稿里，还有一句菲利斯的额外台词。那是菲利斯在迈克尔说出他的
age. I live for it every time. It didn't make it into the episode, but I want to read it. Kevin says, Michael, you're at least 46. Michael says, why at least if 46 is your guess, just say 46. Phyllis would have said, you're 47. We were in the same class. Michael gets so mad. He goes, were you held back a decade? And then he storms out. Oh my gosh. Oh, I love it. I love it so much. We should let you know our head makeup artist Laverne made the cold sore for Michael's lip. She did a very good job. Always. Michael is going to end up covering his cold sore with a bandage. Yeah. And the reason they did that was so that Laverne wouldn't have to try and match that same cold sore makeup every day. Yeah. It would have been very difficult. Well, the next scene
年龄时总是会有的梗。我每次都期待着它。它没能进入正片，但我还是想读一下。凯文说，迈克尔，你至少46岁了。迈克尔说，为什么是至少？如果46岁是你的猜测，直接说46岁就行了。菲利斯本会说，你47岁。我们在同一个班。迈克尔气坏了。他说，你是留级了十年吗？然后他冲了出去。天哪。哦，我喜欢它。我太喜欢它了。我们应该让你知道，我们的首席化妆师拉文为迈克尔的嘴唇制作了那个唇疱疹。她做得非常好。一直都很好。迈克尔最终会用创可贴盖住他的唇疱疹。是的。他们这样做的原因是，拉文就不必每天尝试去匹配那个相同的唇疱疹妆容了。是的。那会非常困难。好吧，下一个场景
should be labeled snark in the break room because there's some snarkiness. Yeah. Everyone is in there and they're discussing Meredith's herpes basically. They're kind of trash in her. But Andy is going to stand up for her. He's going to say everyone should chill out on the herp talk. This is when we learned he was an RA in college and that the number one STD is ignorance. Mm hmm. Erin is impressed. I have a fan catch lady. Okay. From Riley M in Nashville, Tennessee. I just want to say Riley, I'm very impressed. What is it? This is a very quick catch, but it is there. There is a continuity error. They're all in the break room. And around four minutes, you can see the back of Meredith's head. But then later she enters. Oh, good catch. Yeah. So
应该被标记为休息室里的讽刺，因为里面有一些讽刺。是的。每个人都在那里，他们基本上在讨论梅雷迪思的疱疹。他们有点在说她的坏话。但安迪要为她挺身而出。他要说每个人都应该对疱疹的话题冷静点。这时我们才知道他在大学时是宿舍管理员，而且第一大性病是无知。嗯哼。艾琳印象深刻。我有一个粉丝发现，女士。好的。来自田纳西州纳什维尔的莱利·M。我只想说莱利，我印象非常深刻。是什么？这是一个非常快的发现，但它确实存在。有一个连续性错误。他们都在休息室里。在大约四分钟的时候，你可以看到梅雷迪思的后脑勺。但后来她才走进来。哦，好发现。是的。所以
there's this reaction shot of Andy. It sweeps over to Erin and Gabe listening in. This was clearly a shot that they borrowed from later in the scene and moved it up earlier because they liked it because it is 100% the back of Meredith's head. Riley applause. I know. I was so impressed. I mean, blink and you'll miss it. Lady, this scene ends with one of my favorite moments, which is Angela storming out. And once she's out of the break room, you see that she's been holding her breath. Oh yeah. That was 100% scripted. This is how it read in the shooting draft. Meredith sits at a table with Angela and Kevin. Angela quickly packs up her lunch and exits the room. As soon as she leaves the room, she inhales deeply, revealing she'd been holding her breath.
有一个安迪的反应镜头。它扫向了正在偷听的艾琳和盖博。这显然是一个他们从场景后面借来并提前移动的镜头，因为他们喜欢它，因为它100%是梅雷迪思的后脑勺。莱利鼓掌。我知道。我印象太深刻了。我的意思是，眨眼你就会错过它。女士，这个场景以我最喜欢的时刻之一结束，那就是安吉拉冲了出去。一旦她离开休息室，你就会看到她一直在屏住呼吸。哦，是的。那是100%写在剧本里的。拍摄草稿里是这样写的：梅雷迪思坐在安吉拉和凯文的桌子旁。安吉拉迅速收拾好午餐离开房间。她一离开房间，就深吸了一口气，显示她一直在屏住呼吸。
Meredith takes out a sandwich. Amazing. Well, Michael and Dwight are researching the possible cause of herpes on his office computer. Mm hmm. Dwight is going to tell Michael, you need to reach out to all of your lovers and tell them you have herpes. Yeah. Michael says he feels like an old timey sailor with VD. What port did he get his herpes? Was it the Jan port? Was it the Holly port? Oh, don't go there. Don't go to the Holly port. Do not. Dwight, in fact, says that if Michael doesn't contact all of his ex lovers and tell them what's going on, he'll do it for him. Yeah. I love how Dwight just goes zero to 60. He always does. He says, you need to call Holly and tell her she's crawling with herpes. Yes, exactly. Crawling.
梅雷迪思拿出一个三明治。太棒了。好吧，迈克尔和德怀特正在他的办公室电脑上研究疱疹的可能原因。嗯哼。德怀特要告诉迈克尔，你需要联系你所有的爱人，告诉她们你有疱疹。是的。迈克尔说他感觉自己像个得了性病的老派水手。他在哪个港口染上的疱疹？是简港口吗？还是霍莉港口？哦，别提那个。别去霍莉港口。千万别。事实上，德怀特说如果迈克尔不联系他所有的前任并告诉她们发生了什么，他会替他做。是的。我喜欢德怀特那种从零到一百的速度。他总是这样。他说，你需要给霍莉打电话，告诉她她身上爬满了疱疹。是的，没错。爬满了。
Well, this is the time when I thought we could have our sex education. Oh, Lordy. This is courtesy of Courtney B. in Georgia. Buckle in. Who said, I know y'all's browser history must be crazy, so I did a little deep dive for you. Thank you, Courtney, saving our search engine. Courtney says, for background, I'm in nursing school and we actually just learned about the herpes viruses. Oh, there are two main categories of the herpes virus, herpes simplex, which is type one, and herpes simplex virus type two. Type one is the one associated with cold sores, also known as oral herpes. It can be spread to others by saliva and kissing, but it can also be transmitted to the genitals. Something as simple as touching your lips and then using the bathroom
好吧，这是我想我们可以进行性教育的时候了。哦，天哪。这是考特尼·B在佐治亚州的贡献。系好安全带。她说，我知道你们的浏览器历史记录一定很疯狂，所以我为你们做了一点深入研究。谢谢你，考特尼，拯救了我们的搜索引擎。考特尼说，作为背景，我在读护理学校，我们实际上刚刚学了疱疹病毒。哦，疱疹病毒主要有两大类，单纯疱疹，也就是1型，和单纯疱疹病毒2型。1型是与唇疱疹相关的，也称为口腔疱疹。它可以通过唾液和接吻传播给他人，但也可以传播到生殖器。像触摸嘴唇然后上厕所这样简单的事情
can transmit the virus to your genitals, although it will not be as severe as if you actually had genital herpes, which is the official type two. Type two is spread through sexual contact or to a newborn baby via the birth canal. So if you're a woman who has genital herpes, you have to get a C-section. Both types are lifelong infections, but you can control the symptoms with antiviral medications. Most of herpes one, which are the oral herpes, most of those transmissions actually occur in childhood, or you can kiss someone with a cold sore. So Courtney went on to say, as a student nurse, it was hilarious to watch this episode knowing that Michael was causing an unnecessary panic by revealing his herpes infection to his
就可以将病毒传播到你的生殖器，尽管它不会像你真的患有生殖器疱疹（即官方的2型）那样严重。2型通过性接触或在出生时传播给新生儿。所以如果你是一个患有生殖器疱疹的女性，你必须进行剖腹产。这两种类型都是终身感染，但你可以通过抗病毒药物控制症状。大多数疱疹1型，也就是口腔疱疹，大多数传播实际上发生在童年时期，或者你可以亲吻一个有唇疱疹的人。所以考特尼接着说，作为一名学生护士，看着这一集真是太搞笑了，因为我知道迈克尔在没有上下文的情况下向他的
past lovers without any context. Courtney says, thank you for listening to my PSA. Jenna, Angela, if you have any other questions about either of the herpes viruses, I am sending you a great website with accurate information. Thank you, Courtney. Yes, we will share that in our stories. Yes, I appreciate you sharing this information, Courtney, because herpes infections are very common and nothing to be ashamed about. And really, the important thing is that people are informed, which is something that Michael is clearly not. And Courtney, I agree with you. Why didn't anyone else in the office say anything about it being oral herpes? I thought the same thing. But also, many people say Pam says it. Carol later says, Michael, have you had it looked
过去的情人透露他的疱疹感染，引起了不必要的恐慌。考特尼说，谢谢你们听我的公益广告。詹娜，安吉拉，如果你们对这两种疱疹病毒还有任何其他问题，我会发给你们一个很棒的网站，上面有准确的信息。谢谢你，考特尼。是的，我们会在我们的故事里分享它。是的，我很感激你分享这些信息，考特尼，因为疱疹感染非常普遍，没什么好羞耻的。真正重要的是人们要知情，而迈克尔显然并不知情。考特尼，我同意你的观点。为什么办公室里没有其他人说这是口腔疱疹？我也这么想。但也有很多人说，帕姆说了。卡罗尔后来问，迈克尔，你让医生看过了吗？卡罗尔实际上接着说，这在拍摄草稿里，但没能进入正片。她说，迈克尔，你知道生殖器疱疹和口腔疱疹的区别，对吧？口腔疱疹没什么大不了的。那是不同的病毒。她说了，但没能进入正片。但我猜如果迈克尔真的明白了，我们就没有这一集了。出于某种原因，我记得迈克尔发现那根本不是疱疹。我去了拍摄草稿。我没找到那个。但我发誓，安吉拉，那是一个结尾，结果发现那只是一个内生毛发。他们在最后一幕和奥斯卡对话时提到了它，德怀特说，我们很确定那是内生毛发。也许这就是我所想的。但这基本上都是不必要的。
at by a doctor? Carol actually went on to say it's in the shooting draft, but it didn't make it in the episode. She says, Michael, you know the difference between genital and oral herpes, right? Oral is no big deal. It's a different virus. She says that, but it didn't make it in. But I guess if Michael had really clued in, we wouldn't have an episode. For some reason, I remembered that Michael finds out that it wasn't herpes all along. I went to the shooting draft. I couldn't find that. But I swear, Angela, that was a button that it turns out it was like an ingrown hair. They reference it at the very final scene with Oscar Dwight says, we're pretty sure it's an ingrown hair. Maybe that's what I'm thinking of. But this was all unnecessary, basically.
由医生诊断的吗？卡罗尔实际上接着说，这在拍摄剧本里，但没能放进正片。她说，迈克尔，你知道生殖器疱疹和口腔疱疹的区别吧？口腔疱疹没什么大不了的，那是另一种病毒。她说了这些，但没剪进去。但我猜如果迈克尔真的搞清楚了，我们就没这集看了。不知为何，我记得迈克尔最后发现那根本不是疱疹。我查了拍摄剧本，没找到那段。但我发誓，安吉拉，那本来有个结尾，结果发现只是个内生毛发。他们在奥斯卡出现的最后一个场景里提到了，德怀特说，我们很确定那是内生毛发。也许我想到的是那个。但这一切基本上都是多余的。
Well, really what this episode is is a journey for Michael to face the fact that he blows relationships out of proportion, except not with Holly. And that's the real heart of this whole episode. First, there's going to be a lot of shenanigans we have to cover. Well, the first person he's going to call is Donna. I think this is a good place to start. This was his last lover. I know. Michael's like, do you or your stupid husband have herpes? But first, he says that he has a sexually transmitted disease and he spells it H-I. I know. And she's like, oh, my God. He's like R. I know. She's like spelling herpes wrong. I know. Guys, Amy Pete's really came in for that phone call. She was offstage. She was at a phone that
好吧，这一集真正讲述的是迈克尔面对他夸大关系的事实，除了霍莉。这是这一集真正的核心。首先，我们要涵盖很多恶作剧。好吧，他要打给的第一个人是唐娜。我认为这是一个很好的起点。这是他最后一个情人。我知道。迈克尔说，你或者你那个愚蠢的丈夫有疱疹吗？但首先，他说他患有性传播疾病，然后他拼写了H-I。我知道。她说，哦，天哪。他说R。我知道。她在拼错疱疹。我知道。伙计们，艾米·皮茨真的来打那个电话了。她在后台。她在迈克尔办公室里的一部
was hardwired in to Michael's office so they could speak live, but they recorded her on a separate microphone so that, you know, they would get clean sound for the final edit. Michael's next phone call is going to be Holly. This is the cutest thing. It's such a great scene. Hi, this is Holly. No, this is Holly. No, this is Michael Scott. What are you calling about? There's been a horrible accident. Did any nuns die? Two. It's like, Dwight is so confused. I love everything Rain does in this scene. He's like pointing to his lip, like trying to remind Michael. Bring it up. We had a fan question from Kathleen B and Sydney Australia and many others actually who said, is it just me or does the voice of Holly on the phone
硬连线电话上，这样他们可以现场对话，但他们用单独的麦克风录制了她，这样，你知道，他们可以为最终剪辑获得干净的声音。迈克尔的下一个电话是打给霍莉。这是最可爱的事情。这是一个很棒的场景。嗨，我是霍莉。不，我是霍莉。不，我是迈克尔·斯科特。你打电话是为了什么？发生了一起可怕的事故。有修女死亡吗？两个。就像，德怀特非常困惑。我喜欢雷恩在这个场景中所做的一切。他指着自己的嘴唇，好像在提醒迈克尔。提出来。我们有一个来自澳大利亚悉尼的凯瑟琳·B以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们说，是我一个人觉得霍莉在电话里的声音
sound nothing like Amy Ryan? Well, it was Amy Ryan. Yeah, it sounded like it to me, but she was not in the studio. A fan catch from Eric L in Colorado is going to explain that Holly's phone number is shown with a 212 area code, not a Nashua area code. Oh, that's right. She was in New York. And the number that they show on the phone was a real phone number. It was Amy Ryan's agent in New York. Did her agent start getting lots of phone calls? I mean, I called it. Did you really? I got voicemail. Did you really? They should change their number. I don't want to say the number because it's still a working number. But guess what? Jenna just shared that it is a real number and you can zoom in and call it. Sorry, person who has that number. You're going to want to change
听起来一点也不像艾米·瑞恩吗？好吧，那就是艾米·瑞恩。是的，听起来像我，但她不在录音室里。来自科罗拉多州埃里克·L的粉丝发现将解释说，霍莉的电话号码显示的是212区号，而不是纳舒厄区号。哦，对了。她在纽约。而且他们在电话上显示的号码是一个真实的电话号码。那是艾米·瑞恩在纽约的经纪人的号码。她的经纪人开始接到很多电话了吗？我的意思是，我打了。你真的打了吗？我得到了语音信箱。你真的打了吗？他们应该换号码。我不想说出那个号码，因为它仍然是一个工作号码。但猜猜怎么着？詹娜刚刚分享说这是一个真实的号码，你可以放大并拨打它。抱歉，拥有那个号码的人。你很快就会想换掉
that real soon. Yeah. So Amy was really in New York. They had a sound recordist named Adam Sanchez who was in New York with her recording her half of the dialogue, but her and Steve could really hear one another and they could react off one another in real time. Yeah. And they went off script a little bit like they're so good together. I know. Well, in this conversation with Holly, Michael is going to get nostalgic and he's going to say, do you ever wonder what it would have been like if you hadn't been transferred? Michael says they'd be married. They have twins. Yeah. Yeah. We were so the same person right there. I know. And that's when Holly says to Michael, I think you romanticize things. Like, I think you blow them up to be bigger than what they
那个号码。是的。所以艾米确实在纽约。他们有一位名叫亚当·桑切斯的录音师在纽约和她一起录制她的对话部分，但她和史蒂夫真的能听到对方，他们可以实时做出反应。是的。他们稍微脱离了剧本，因为他们在一起太棒了。我知道。好吧，在与霍莉的这次谈话中，迈克尔会变得怀旧，他会说，你有没有想过如果你没有被调走会是什么样子？迈克尔说他们会结婚。他们会有双胞胎。是的。是的。我们在那一刻真是同一个人。我知道。就在那时，霍莉对迈克尔说，我认为你把事情浪漫化了。就像，我认为你把它们吹得比它们
really were. Yeah. She goes, you know what? We had a fling a long time ago. Well, this is crushing to Michael. Oh, breaks his heart. He gets off the phone. He didn't even mention the herpes. No, it didn't come up organically. And this idea that he blows things out of proportion, this is going to stick with him. It's going to be a big part of his conversations for the rest of the day. Why don't we take a quick break? Because when we come back, Andy is going to have pizzas. If anyone wants to have an honest discussion about the sexual mores and taboos of society, Andy, you can have a slice. We'll be right back. Well, we're back. And I hope you're hungry because Andy has a lot of pizza and he wants you to come in the conference room to talk about
实际的样子要大。是的。她说，你知道吗？我们很久以前有过一段恋情。好吧，这对迈克尔来说是毁灭性的。哦，伤透了他的心。他挂了电话。他甚至没提疱疹的事。不，它没有自然地出现。这种他把事情夸大的想法，会一直伴随着他。这将是他余下一天谈话的重要部分。我们为什么不休息一下呢？因为当我们回来时，安迪会有披萨。如果有人想就社会的性道德和禁忌进行诚实的讨论，安迪，你可以吃一片。我们马上回来。好吧，我们回来了。我希望你饿了，因为安迪有很多披萨，他想让你到会议室来谈谈
sex. Not everyone is happy about the pizza. Oh, yeah. In fact, Ryan is ticked off. It's in the shooting draft. It's even in deleted scenes. He starts flipping the pizza lids open with this dramatic effect. Here's how it read in the script. Ryan flipping pepperoni, meatball, Hawaiian pizza, veggie delight, artichoke. He's furious. People are on Ryan's side now. They're eating the pizza, but they're complaining. Andy says, just pick the stuff off. Phyllis says, then the cheese comes off. Andy says, you know that's not true. There's a way to do it carefully. Now, I'm going to show you a picture of genitalia and that's how the scene in the conference room starts. Well, lady, I remember shooting that. I remember BJ flipping the pizza lids and also I noted in
性。并不是每个人都对披萨感到高兴。哦，是的。事实上，瑞恩很生气。这在拍摄草稿里。甚至在删除的场景里也有。他开始用这种戏剧性的效果翻开披萨盖子。剧本里是这样写的：瑞恩翻开意大利辣香肠、肉丸、夏威夷披萨、蔬菜精选、洋蓟。他很愤怒。人们现在站在瑞恩这边。他们在吃披萨，但他们在抱怨。安迪说，把东西挑掉就行了。菲利斯说，那奶酪也会掉下来。安迪说，你知道那不是真的。有一种方法可以小心地做到这一点。现在，我要给你们看一张生殖器的照片，这就是会议室场景开始的方式。好吧，女士，我记得拍摄那个场景。我记得BJ翻开披萨盖子，我也注意到在
the conference room that everybody's pizza has some form of meat on it or topping. It's pepperoni. Almost all of them are pepperoni. He didn't get any just plain cheese pizza. Not one. Well, Jenna, I noticed something else besides a lot of pepperoni. What's that? Jim and Pam are not sitting next to each other. And if you go to 10 minutes, 24 seconds, you see Pam wave Jim off. What's happening? Oh, lady, I'm sure you uncovered this. In your research, there was a huge deleted Jim Pam storyline from this episode. It's bonkers. It's really weird. I have it all from the shooting draft. I can share it, and then you can share about shooting it. Please. All right. It read like this.
会议室里，每个人的披萨上都有某种肉类或配料。是意大利辣香肠。几乎所有披萨都是意大利辣香肠。他没有买任何纯奶酪披萨。一个都没有。好吧，詹娜，除了很多意大利辣香肠，我还注意到了别的东西。是什么？吉姆和帕姆没有坐在一起。如果你看到10分24秒，你会看到帕姆挥手让吉姆走开。发生了什么？哦，女士，我相信你发现了这个。在你的研究中，这一集有一个巨大的被删除的吉姆和帕姆的故事线。太疯狂了。真的很奇怪。我从拍摄草稿里得到了所有内容。我可以分享它，然后你可以分享拍摄它的过程。请。好的。它是这样写的：
At the top of the episode, Pam walks in and puts her stuff down. A few beats later, Jim walks in and puts his stuff down. They avoid each other's gazes. The camera sort of notices it, but then gets distracted by Michael and his fake mustache. This continues. Later in the kitchen, Pam and Toby are talking and Jim walks in. The script read, Pam looks at Jim. He's surprised that she's in there. Toby says, Hey, Jim. Jim says, Hi, Toby. Jim looks at Pam. Pam walks out. Jim watches her go. He seems tense. Toby looks to camera like yikes. Then there's a Jim and Pam joint talking head where Jim says, No, not at all. And then he puts his hand on her forearm to show affection. And she removes it. Then Toby has a talking head where he seems ecstatic. And he just says, Yikes.
在这一集的开头，帕姆走进来放下她的东西。几拍之后，吉姆走进来放下他的东西。他们避开对方的目光。摄像机注意到这一点，但随后被迈克尔和他的假胡子分散了注意力。这种情况持续着。后来在厨房里，帕姆和托比在谈话，吉姆走了进来。剧本写道：帕姆看着吉姆。他很惊讶她在那里。托比说，嘿，吉姆。吉姆说，嗨，托比。吉姆看着帕姆。帕姆走开了。吉姆看着她离开。他看起来很紧张。托比对着镜头做出“哎呀”的表情。然后有一个吉姆和帕姆的联合访谈，吉姆说，不，一点也不。然后他把手放在她的前臂上表示亲昵。她移开了。然后托比有一个访谈，他看起来欣喜若狂。他只是说，哎呀。
The next beat involves Kelly in the kitchen. Pam is making herself coffee. Kelly is at the counter. She's struggling to open a jar of, and it says, I quote, marshmallow fluff. Oh, just making a fluffer nutter, guys. Jim comes out of the men's room and Kelly asks him to help open the jar. He can't open it. He really struggles with it. Kelly uses this as an opportunity to try to get Ryan dating advice. And Jim seems miserable. And he hands the jar back to her, unable to open it. And Pam smiles slightly. She's kind of enjoyed watching Jim struggle with Kelly. Then in the conference room, as we just talked about, Jim walks in, Pam has already seated, and Darrell offers to get up so Jim can sit next to his wife. And Pam is waving Darrell off,
下一个节拍涉及厨房里的凯利。帕姆正在给自己泡咖啡。凯利在柜台边。她正在努力打开一罐，我引用，棉花糖酱。哦，只是在做一个棉花糖三明治，伙计们。吉姆从男厕所出来，凯利让他帮忙打开罐子。他打不开。他真的很费劲。凯利利用这个机会试图从瑞恩那里得到约会建议。吉姆看起来很痛苦。他把罐子还给她，没能打开。帕姆微微一笑。她有点喜欢看吉姆和凯利纠缠。然后在会议室里，正如我们刚才谈到的，吉姆走进来，帕姆已经坐下了，达里尔主动提出起身让吉姆坐在他妻子旁边。帕姆挥手让达里尔走开，
not Jim. Like, no, no, no. Stay, Darrell. Stay. Yeah. Well, this whole thing was because the writers were trying to come up with conflict for Jim and Pam. Storylines for Jim and Pam, now that they were married. And they thought, how about they're in a fight one day at work, where they're not talking to each other. Non-serious conflict. Yes. But like, it's one of those things. Yeah. And, you know, they're having that day. The way it was explained to me was that if they had gone to different jobs, they wouldn't have like texted and called all day. They just would have had their little time out and they probably would have been fine when they got home. They did not want this to be like a big serious disagreement. But they work at the same
而不是吉姆。就像，不，不，不。留着，达里尔。留着。是的。好吧，这一切都是因为编剧们试图为吉姆和帕姆制造冲突。吉姆和帕姆的故事线，既然他们已经结婚了。他们想，如果他们有一天在工作中吵架，互不理睬怎么样？非严重的冲突。是的。但就像，这是那种事情之一。是的。而且，你知道，他们正在经历那一天。向我解释的方式是，如果他们去了不同的工作岗位，他们就不会整天发短信和打电话。他们只会有一个小小的暂停，当他们回家时可能就没事了。他们不想让这成为一场重大的严重分歧。但他们在同一个
place. So they had to go to work together. And they're just kind of each giving the other the silent treatment. Yeah. They're just annoyed. And the idea was that it would all play out in silences and little moments and that the camera would kind of catch it. We had huge discussions over what this fight would be. We ultimately, we thought this was kind of a fun little thing. We came up with our own reason. Oh. And we didn't tell the other person. Oh. Because we thought that would add a layer to this silent play that we were doing. It all got cut out. Well, it actually does resolve itself in the shooting draft, which you never see. The very last Jim and Pam scene is the end of the work day. In the script, it read like this.
地方工作。所以他们必须一起去上班。他们只是在给对方冷处理。是的。他们只是很烦。这个想法是，这一切都会在沉默和微小的时刻中上演，摄像机也会捕捉到它。我们对这场争吵会是什么样子进行了激烈的讨论。我们最终认为这是一种有趣的小事情。我们想出了我们自己的理由。哦。而且我们没有告诉对方。哦。因为我们认为这会为我们正在进行的这场无声表演增加一层深度。这一切都被剪掉了。好吧，它实际上在拍摄草稿里解决了，你永远看不到。最后一个吉姆和帕姆的场景是工作日的结束。在剧本里，它是这样写的：
As Michael and Dwight head inside, they pass Jim and Pam leaving for the day. We follow Jim and Pam in a spy shot. Jim says, Hey, you know, I don't even remember what we were fighting about. Pam says, I do. And then Jim says, I do too. I'm sorry. He holds out his hand. She takes it. She says, me too. And they continue walking. I mean, ultimately, I thought it was a really realistic sort of marital couple-y thing. Yeah. But I mean, it didn't end up totally working. I think you can see some of it in deleted scenes. Oh, yeah, you can. Yeah. Yeah. But I mean, you can't play it because it's just silent. Yeah. Yeah. Like I was going to play the scene between Jim and Kelly and Pam in the kitchen, but it's just Kelly talking and the two of you looking
当迈克尔和德怀特走进去时，他们经过了下班离开的吉姆和帕姆。我们用间谍镜头跟随吉姆和帕姆。吉姆说，嘿，你知道，我甚至不记得我们在吵什么了。帕姆说，我记得。然后吉姆说，我也记得。对不起。他伸出手。她握住了。她说，我也是。然后他们继续走。我的意思是，最终，我认为这是一个非常现实的已婚夫妇的事情。是的。但我的意思是，它最终并没有完全奏效。我想你可以在删除的场景里看到一些。哦，是的，你可以。是的。是的。但我的意思是，你不能播放它，因为它只是沉默。是的。是的。就像我本来要播放吉姆和凯利和帕姆在厨房里的场景，但那只是凯利在说话，你们两个看起来
awkwardly. Yeah. Yeah. Well, while Jim and Pam are sitting with Daryl between them, sort of picking at their pizza, Andy is going to start showing pictures of genitalia, some of which have herpes. Yeah. My favorite line coming from John Krasinski as Jim. Am I blocking anyone? Can everyone see? I loved it. We had a fan question from Kyle T. in Houston, Texas. What was actually on the pictures of blurred out genitalia? This required some real detective work, lady, because Randy Cordray, knower of all things, is on vacation. I know. We traded a bunch of emails about this episode, and then he went on vacation. And we said, have a great vacation. We're not going to bug you
很尴尬。是的。是的。好吧，当吉姆和帕姆坐在一起，达里尔在他们中间，有点在挑剔他们的披萨时，安迪要开始展示生殖器的照片，其中一些有疱疹。是的。我最喜欢的台词来自约翰·卡拉辛斯基饰演的吉姆。我挡住谁了吗？大家都能看到吗？我喜欢它。我们有一个来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的凯尔·T的粉丝提问。模糊处理的生殖器照片上到底是什么？这需要一些真正的侦探工作，女士，因为兰迪·科德雷，万事通，正在度假。我知道。我们关于这一集交换了一堆电子邮件，然后他就去度假了。我们说，祝你假期愉快。我们不会打扰你
about possible genitalia. We're not. We're not. Not on your vacation, Randy. Not on your vacation. No. But I had a late breaking question, which was, what was on the pictures of the genitalia? I was like, I have to figure it out. Well, I had a call sheet from this episode, thanks to James Carey. Way to go, James. And it said we had a still photographer on set, on this day, the day we were shooting conference room scenes with pictures of genitalia. Yeah. Guess what? What? There are photos of this scene, and they are not blurred. The first one that Andy holds up, the picture of the man with the ripped abs, that man is wearing underwear. The second one, the picture itself is pixelated.
关于可能的生殖器。我们不会。我们不会。不在你的假期，兰迪。不在你的假期。不。但我有一个突发问题，那就是，生殖器照片上是什么？我当时想，我必须弄清楚。好吧，多亏了詹姆斯·凯里，我有一份这一集的通告单。干得好，詹姆斯。上面说我们那天在片场有一位静态摄影师，那天我们正在拍摄会议室场景，上面有生殖器的照片。是的。猜猜怎么着？什么？有这个场景的照片，而且它们没有被模糊。安迪举起的第一个，那个有着健美腹肌的男人的照片，那个男人穿着内衣。第二个，照片本身是像素化的。
Right. And then we further blurred it. We saw no genitalia on this day. We did not. We did not. We had another question about this scene from Levi A. in Northampton, Massachusetts, who wanted to know, was there a reason that we are sitting in the conference room along the wall? Because I don't think you've ever sat like that before. No table in the middle. We're also not in rows. Yeah. I feel like there's a few times we were like that, like for Jans, baby shower, you know, there's every once in a while, but it's not the usual. The writers were looking for ways to put other characters in charge of the office,
对。然后我们进一步模糊了它。那天我们没有看到任何生殖器。我们没有。我们没有。我们还有另一个关于这个场景的问题，来自马萨诸塞州北安普顿的列维·A，他想知道，我们坐在会议室沿着墙壁坐是有原因的吗？因为我不认为你们以前那样坐过。中间没有桌子。我们也不是排成行。是的。我觉得有几次我们是那样的，比如为了简的迎婴派对，你知道，偶尔会有一次，但这不是通常的情况。编剧们正在寻找方法让其他角色负责办公室，
to see how those dynamics would play out. And this was part of that experimenting that they were doing, you know, because the character of Michael was leaving. And the reason we're sitting this way was because they wanted to differentiate between Michael leading a conference room meeting and another character. And Andy. And they even put Andy in the back corner, rather than the front of the room. So this was just a choice. Mm-hmm. And like you said, it was also sort of presented as an informal pizza party. Yeah. And so this was how Andy runs a conference room meeting. We sit around the wall, like we're in the dorm, because that's how he ran his meetings as an RA, probably so.
看看这些动态会如何发展。这是他们正在做的实验的一部分，你知道，因为迈克尔这个角色要离开了。我们这样坐的原因是他们想区分迈克尔主持会议室会议和其他角色。还有安迪。他们甚至把安迪放在后角，而不是房间的前面。所以这只是一个选择。嗯哼。就像你说的，它也被呈现为一种非正式的披萨派对。是的。所以这就是安迪主持会议室会议的方式。我们围着墙坐，就像我们在宿舍里一样，因为那是他作为宿舍管理员主持会议的方式，大概是这样。
Next up is one of my favorite scenes of this whole episode, because we get to see Michael and Jan in the same room together. Here, Milora and Steve are just so incredible as these two people. They bring out the worst in each other, always. Michael and Dwight have arrived to the lobby of Jan's new office building. Listen, she'll be with them shortly. Mm-hmm. She's busy. She is. How does she work? As the director of office purchasing for this hospital, while raising a daughter and releasing an album of Doris Stay Covers on her own label. If she knew she'd tell you. Yeah. Yeah. I have a location breakdown for you. Okay. The exterior establishing shot of this hospital
接下来是这一整集中我最喜欢的场景之一，因为我们能看到迈克尔和简在同一个房间里。在这里，米洛拉和史蒂夫作为这两个人真是太不可思议了。他们总是激发出对方最坏的一面。迈克尔和德怀特到达了简新办公大楼的大厅。听着，她很快就会和他们在一起。嗯哼。她很忙。她是。她怎么工作？作为这家医院的办公室采购总监，同时抚养一个女儿，并在自己的厂牌下发行了一张多丽丝·戴翻唱专辑。如果她知道，她会告诉你的。是的。是的。我有一个地点细分给你。好的。这家医院的外景建立镜头
was Kaiser Permanente in Panorama City, but the entire interior was shot on our warehouse stage. We did not build this set. Randy Cordray, before leaving for a vacation, told me that it was a rental. We rented it from 20th Century Fox. They had a recently canceled series called Taxman, and they had kind of taken the set and put it in a warehouse. They were willing to rent it out, so we rented it. That's how we got it. Well, Jan is a super mom. If she does say so herself. Exactly. Apparently, Jan can bring home the bacon and fry it up in the pan. Mm-hmm. She's like, remember that commercial? Mm-hmm. Dwight's like, I don't know what you're talking about. Jan had to sing immediately. She had to sing right away. Within 15 seconds. Yeah.
是全景城的凯撒医疗中心，但整个内景是在我们的仓库舞台上拍摄的。我们没有搭建这个布景。兰迪·科德雷在去度假前告诉我，这是一个租赁的。我们从20世纪福克斯租的。他们有一个最近被取消的系列剧叫《税务员》，他们把布景拿走放在了一个仓库里。他们愿意出租，所以我们就租了。这就是我们得到它的方式。好吧，简是一位超级妈妈。如果她自己这么说的话。确切地。显然，简可以把培根带回家并在平底锅里煎熟。嗯哼。她就像，还记得那个广告吗？嗯哼。德怀特说，我不知道你在说什么。简必须立即唱歌。她必须马上唱歌。在15秒内。是的。
Jan is going to have one of my favorite moments in this episode. I love Malora as this character so much. Michael wants to know, if he's the kind of guy who misremembers the nature of relationships, and Jan looks at him with such intensity and says, Michael Scott, you are here for a postmortem. Michael's like, what? And Jan says, you want to dig into our relationship, go over it, see what killed it. Okay, I'm in. At that point, just leave, because it's only going to get weirder from there. Yes, they're going over it, and Michael's not getting any of her analogies. Her analogy, where she is a princess dating below her station, but she's also the queen. She's both. Michael's like, am I at the guy at the station? Exactly. So now Astrid comes in.
简在这一集中会有我最喜欢的时刻之一。我非常喜欢米洛拉饰演的这个角色。迈克尔想知道，如果他是那种误记关系本质的人，简带着强烈的感情看着他说，迈克尔·斯科特，你是来做尸检的。迈克尔说，什么？简说，你想挖掘我们的关系，回顾它，看看是什么杀死了它。好吧，我加入。在那一点上，直接离开，因为从那以后只会变得更奇怪。是的，他们正在回顾它，而迈克尔根本听不懂她的类比。她的类比，她是地位低于她的公主，但她也是女王。她两者都是。迈克尔说，我是那个在车站的人吗？确切地。所以现在阿斯特丽德进来了。
She's with her nanny who was played by Marilyn Zach. Baby Astrid was played by Molly Burke. Cutest little kid. And Malora made the choice to sing to Astrid about her day. This was not in the script. None of this dialogue. She was just going to say, how was your day? And then she starts singing to her. Oh, we have to hear it, because it's amazing. And it's the last time we're going to hear Jan sing on the office. Asi, oh, how was school? It was cool. What did you learn? What did I learn? You might have learned shapes, or blocks, or clocks, or colors, or you might have learned that we're all sisters and brothers. I have her face. But Michael just sees Jan for truly who she is, as she's singing to her daughter. And he has a
她和她的保姆在一起，保姆由玛丽琳·扎克饰演。婴儿阿斯特丽德由莫莉·伯克饰演。最可爱的小孩。米洛拉做出了一个选择，给阿斯特丽德唱关于她一天的歌。这不在剧本里。这些对话都没有。她本来只是要说，你今天过得怎么样？然后她开始对她唱歌。哦，我们必须听听，因为它太棒了。这是我们最后一次在《办公室》里听到简唱歌。阿西，哦，学校怎么样？很酷。你学到了什么？我学到了什么？你可能学到了形状，或者积木，或者时钟，或者颜色，或者你可能学到了我们都是姐妹和兄弟。我有她的脸。但迈克尔只是看到了简真正是谁，当她对女儿唱歌时。他有一个
talking head where he says he thought she was the one, or A, the one. And if he was wrong about that, yeah. Was he wrong about Holly? Yeah. Back in the conference room, Andy wants to make a list of pros and cons to having sex. And the first con is risk of STDs. Can anybody come up with any more? No, all of the things being shouted out by Kevin, even Phyllis, are like amazing, magical. Creed says the feeling of pure risk. And Andy's like, well, I had that in the con column, but okay, fine. You know, I'll put it in the pro column. Aaron suggests a con, unplanned pregnancy. Kelly and Kevin say, like CeCe, was a mistake. Oh boy. Jim and Pam are going to get fired up on that one. She was a surprise, a welcome surprise. Yeah. So now Andy has to put unplanned pregnancy
访谈镜头，他说他以为她是那个，或者A，那个。如果他在那件事上错了，是的。他在霍莉这件事上错了吗？是的。回到会议室，安迪想列一个性行为的利弊清单。第一个弊端是性传播疾病的风险。有人能想出更多吗？不，凯文甚至菲利斯喊出的所有东西，都是神奇的。克里德说纯粹风险的感觉。安迪说，好吧，我把它放在弊端栏里，但好吧，没关系。你知道，我会把它放在优点栏里。艾琳建议了一个弊端，意外怀孕。凯利和凯文说，像西西一样，是个错误。哦，天哪。吉姆和帕姆要在那件事上火冒三丈了。她是一个惊喜，一个受欢迎的惊喜。是的。所以现在安迪必须把意外怀孕
in the pro column. We had a fan question from Sarah S in Chico, California, who said, I heard that this episode is the first time that Oscar broke. Is this true? And can you tell us more about it? Definitely the first time he broke and was busted. Yeah, it's actually on the blooper reel for season seven. I pulled a clip to paint a picture. Ed Helms as Andy is standing up at his whiteboard, and he's doing this crazy thing with his fingers, where he's got like two fingers in front of his mouth. Yeah, he's clasps his hands together and put two fingers kind of on his lips. Like, hmm. He's like, who can tell me some cons? And this gesture really got Oscar. Take a listen. Okay, who can tell me? I'm sorry, I'm sorry. Did you laugh?
放在优点栏里。我们有一个来自加利福尼亚州奇科的莎拉·S的粉丝提问，她说，我听说这一集是奥斯卡第一次笑场。这是真的吗？你能告诉我们更多吗？绝对是他第一次笑场并被抓包。是的，它实际上在第七季的NG片段里。我剪了一个片段来描绘画面。艾德·赫尔姆斯饰演的安迪站在他的白板前，他用手指做着这个疯狂的动作，他有两根手指在嘴前。是的，他双手合十，把两根手指放在嘴唇上。就像，嗯。他说，谁能告诉我一些弊端？这个手势真的让奥斯卡破功了。听听看。好的，谁能告诉我？对不起，对不起。你笑了吗？
Listen to how tickled we all are. Yeah, the man never broke. He was a statue. And this was like a little thing. You know, it wasn't a big thing that got him. It was just this little funny gesture that Ed was doing. And the whole cast and crew started to cheer. Next stop on Michael's herpes tour is Helene, Pam's mom. They find her at the park. Yes, they do. She seems confused. Michael's like, don't you remember me? We were lovers. He's speaking to a totally different woman. This woman was played by Brady Rubin. This is when Helene is going to be like, Michael? She's sitting there with baby Cece. We had a fan question from Molly C in Rochester, New York. How did Michael know to go to the park to find Helene? She seemed surprised to see him,
听听我们大家被逗得有多开心。是的，那个人从不笑场。他是个雕像。这就像一件小事。你知道，不是什么大事让他破功。只是艾德做的这个小小的滑稽手势。整个演员和剧组人员开始欢呼。迈克尔疱疹之旅的下一站是海琳，帕姆的妈妈。他们在公园里找到了她。是的，他们找到了。她看起来很困惑。迈克尔说，你不记得我了吗？我们曾经是恋人。他正在和一个完全不同的女人说话。这个女人由布雷迪·鲁宾饰演。这是海琳要说，迈克尔？的时候。她正和婴儿西西坐在那里。我们有一个来自纽约罗切斯特的莫莉·C的粉丝提问。迈克尔怎么知道去公园找海琳？她看起来很惊讶见到他，
so it doesn't seem like he called ahead and asked her where she was. Well, I'll tell you, there was a line in the script that was cut as they're entering the park where Dwight said to Michael, according to Pam's emails, Helene should be here with Cece. What? They've looked at Pam's email? I know! Apparently they hacked Pam's emails to find Helene's location. Oh my gosh. Yeah. I didn't even know Michael knew how to open his own email. Well, this is clearly Dwight's doing. It's Dwight. It's Dwight. As annoyed as Helene is with Michael, she does tell him his herpes will go away as long as he doesn't touch it. And then he asks her if she thinks he misremembers relationships. She tells
所以看起来他并没有提前打电话问她在哪里。好吧，我告诉你，剧本里有一句被删掉的台词，当他们进入公园时，德怀特对迈克尔说，根据帕姆的电子邮件，海琳应该和西西在这里。什么？他们看了帕姆的电子邮件？我知道！显然他们黑进了帕姆的电子邮件来找到海琳的位置。天哪。是的。我甚至不知道迈克尔知道怎么打开他自己的电子邮件。好吧，这显然是德怀特的杰作。是德怀特。是德怀特。尽管海琳对迈克尔很恼火，但她确实告诉他，只要他不碰它，他的疱疹就会消失。然后他问她是否认为他误记了关系。她告诉
him he's deluded. Pretty much everyone is like, yes. Uh-huh. He calls her a jerk. And then he leaves. That's Pam's mom. Yeah. You jerk. Listen, Pam was against this relationship and for good reason. But she's clearly been like, you know what? You wanted it. Y'all enjoy it. Yeah. Back in the conference room, Andy wants to know if anyone in the office is practicing abstinence. Which he says is the only real form of safe sex. Daryl takes issue with this logic. It's becoming very clear that Andy has set up this whole conference room meeting just to find out if Aaron and Gabe are having sex. Yes. And it's not going to end well. Andy is starting to spiral. He's really bummed that nobody, basically Aaron, is abstinent. So he said, okay, I guess
他他是在自欺欺人。几乎每个人都说，是的。嗯哼。他叫她混蛋。然后他离开了。那是帕姆的妈妈。是的。你这个混蛋。听着，帕姆反对这段关系是有充分理由的。但她显然已经，你知道吗？你想要它。你们享受吧。是的。回到会议室，安迪想知道办公室里是否有人在练习禁欲。他说这是唯一真正的安全套形式。达里尔对这个逻辑有异议。越来越清楚的是，安迪设置整个会议室会议只是为了找出艾琳和盖博是否在发生性关系。是的。而且这不会有好结果。安迪开始失控。他真的很沮丧，没有人，基本上是艾琳，在禁欲。所以他说，好吧，我想
I'm going to have to put a condom onto a pencil. I mean, he can't use his penis. It's not exactly hard anyway. Yeah. And then Meredith is going to say, give it a rest, pencil dick. Guess what? Oh no. Standards and practices. They allowed pencil dick? Well, here was their note. Randy sent it to me. He said this caused a flurry of notes. They said page 30, scene 36, as previously mentioned. So they've clearly had to mention it a lot. Please bleep the word dick and blur Meredith's lip flap when she says it. As previously mentioned. As previously mentioned. Again, with the dick. Can you guys just get on board? Blur it and bleep it. Blur it and bleep it. Cover up that lip flap. I know. That's how they described it. Her lip flap. Anyway. Well, Andy's
我得把避孕套套在铅笔上。我的意思是，他不能用他的阴茎。反正它也不硬。是的。然后梅雷迪思要说，歇会儿吧，铅笔屌。猜猜怎么着？哦，不。标准和实践。他们允许“铅笔屌”？好吧，这是他们的注释。兰迪发给我的。他说这引起了一阵注释。他们说第30页，场景36，如前所述。所以他们显然不得不提到它很多次。请把“屌”这个词消音，并在梅雷迪思说它时模糊她的嘴唇动作。如前所述。如前所述。又是那个词。你们能配合一下吗？模糊它并消音。模糊它并消音。盖住那个嘴唇动作。我知道。他们就是这样描述的。她的嘴唇动作。总之。好吧，安迪
fully going to melt down. Nobody appreciates his effort. He's going to throw a pizza at the wall. Yeah. This is a subtle callback or not so subtle callback to Ryan's pizza rant. It says in the shooting draft, Andy takes the entire untouched veggie pizza and throws it against the window. The room goes silent. Look at the pizza on the wall. There is no meat. I looked. It's all veggies. But I want you to know, I think Angela would have had a piece of veggie pizza. Yeah. Maybe she saved it for the artichoke one though. Maybe she did. I love that you zoomed in to see if there was meat on the pizza. It looks like veggies to me guys. It's commitment to the job. Mm-hmm. Gabe is now going to have a sit down with Andy. He's going to say, you know what?
完全要崩溃了。没有人欣赏他的努力。他要把披萨扔到墙上。是的。这是一个微妙的呼应，或者说不是那么微妙的呼应，呼应瑞恩的披萨咆哮。拍摄草稿里说，安迪拿起整个未动的蔬菜披萨扔向窗户。房间安静了下来。看看墙上的披萨。没有肉。我看了。全是蔬菜。但我希望你知道，我认为安吉拉会吃一片蔬菜披萨。是的。也许她留着它给洋蓟披萨吃。也许她吃了。我喜欢你放大看披萨上有没有肉。对我来说看起来像蔬菜，伙计们。这是对工作的投入。嗯哼。盖博现在要和安迪坐下来谈谈。他要说，你知道吗？
I know that that whole meeting was about me and Aaron and I specifically asked you if it was okay for Aaron and I to go out after you broke up. Gabe says, I remember it because of how you worded it. You said, well, good sir. Nothing would make me happier than to hand you the hand of the hand that was once in my hand. Mm-hmm. In the shooting draft, Andy would have gone on to say, well, I would like you kindly to unhand that hand. Oh, yes. And Gabe was like, you can't unhand a hand once a hand is picked up. It's like ridiculous. Oh, I wish that would have stayed in. It was really funny. Michael and Dwight are now going to arrive at an open house and that means only one thing. It's time for him to speak with Carol Stills. Mm-hmm. I have a location alert. Mm-hmm. We shot
我知道那整个会议是关于我和亚伦的，我特别问过你，在你分手后我和亚伦出去是否可以。盖博说，我记得是因为你的措辞。你说，嗯，好先生。没有什么比把曾经在我手中的那只手交给你更让我高兴的了。嗯哼。在拍摄剧本中，安迪本会接着说，嗯，我想请你放开那只手。哦，是的。盖博当时说，一旦手被牵起，你就不能放开它。这太荒谬了。哦，我真希望那段保留下来。那真的很有趣。迈克尔和德怀特现在要到达一个开放参观日，这意味着只有一件事。是时候让他和卡罗尔·斯蒂尔斯谈谈了。嗯哼。我有一个地点提醒。嗯哼。我们拍摄了
this house on the same day as the Helene Park scenes. And our locations manager, Kyle Alexander, found a private residence on Ledge Avenue in Toluca Lake. And he found a nearby park. So we were able to do both on one day. And Henry Sane made that realty sign that's out front on the lawn. Well, Michael is going to say he's here to buy a house. He's clearly not. Mm-hmm. He asked Carol if he romanticizes relationships. And she says, yeah, you make a bigger deal of things. You propose to me on our fourth date. I have a continuity catch. I do as well. Maria Pee from Miami, Florida and many others, I think, have the same catch, lady. Yes. In Diwali, when Michael proposes to Carol, Carol says it's only their ninth date. Mm-hmm. And here it's their fourth date.
这所房子是在海琳公园场景的同一天拍摄的。我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大在托卢卡湖的莱奇大道上找到了一处私人住宅。他还找到了一个附近的公园。所以我们能够在一天内完成这两个场景。亨利·塞恩制作了草坪前的那块房地产标志。嗯，迈克尔要说他是来买房子的。他显然不是。嗯哼。他问卡罗尔他是否把人际关系浪漫化了。她说，是的，你把事情看得太严重了。你在我们第四次约会时就向我求婚了。我有一个连续性错误。我也有。来自佛罗里达州迈阿密的玛丽亚·皮和其他许多人，我想，都有同样的发现，女士。是的。在排灯节那一集中，当迈克尔向卡罗尔求婚时，卡罗尔说那只是他们的第九次约会。嗯哼。而这里说是他们的第四次约会。
Well, Maria thought maybe Michael proposed twice as he been proposing and proposing and proposing. That's hilarious. Mm-hmm. This is when Dwight comes down the stairs. In the shooting draft, he was originally stuck in the bathroom and had been screaming. And he came down the stairs and said, did no one hear me? I've been locked in the bathroom. Mm-hmm. But in this version, he came downstairs and he said someone died in that bathroom upstairs. And I love Nancy as Carol just goes, no, no, no. Mm-hmm. Didn't happen. The scene with Carol ends Michael's quest and he's going to go back to his office and he's going to call Holly. He is. He gets her voicemail and he leaves her such a great message. Oh my gosh. The fact that Holly did not get in
嗯，玛丽亚认为也许迈克尔求婚了两次，因为他一直在求婚、求婚、再求婚。这太搞笑了。嗯哼。这是德怀特从楼梯上下来的时候。在拍摄剧本中，他最初被困在浴室里一直在尖叫。他走下楼梯说，没人听到我吗？我被锁在浴室里了。嗯哼。但在这一版中，他下楼说楼上那个浴室里有人死了。我喜欢南希饰演的卡罗尔说，不，不，不。嗯哼。没发生过。与卡罗尔的场景结束了迈克尔的探索，他要回到办公室给霍莉打电话。他确实打了。他转到了她的语音信箱，并留下了这么棒的留言。天哪。霍莉在听到这条留言后没有立刻
her car and drive back to Michael the minute she heard this message. What do you need, Holly? What does your heart need? I know. He says, you know what, Holly? You're wrong. You are wrong. I remember every second of us and talking to them today, you know, to the other ladies. He said, I don't feel for them anything like what I feel for you. I didn't joke with any of them. I joked with you. You are the only one who was actually happy to hear from me. And I don't know why you downgraded what we had, but I did not make us up. Oh, wait, you should talk to your doctor because you might have herpes by. Amazing. Well, lady, we got a fan question from Danica G in Des Moines, Iowa, who noticed that there was one woman missing from Michael's tour. Danica would like to know
上车开车回到迈克尔身边，这真是……你需要什么，霍莉？你的心需要什么？我知道。他说，你知道吗，霍莉？你错了。你错了。我记得我们在一起的每一秒，今天和她们谈话时，你知道，和其他女士们。他说，我对她们没有任何感觉，不像我对你的感觉。我没有和她们中的任何一个开玩笑。我只和你开玩笑。你是唯一一个真正高兴听到我消息的人。我不知道你为什么要贬低我们曾经拥有的，但我没有编造我们。哦，等等，你应该去看医生，因为你可能有疱疹，再见。太棒了。嗯，女士，我们收到了来自爱荷华州得梅因的丹妮卡·G的粉丝提问，她注意到迈克尔的巡回访问中少了一位女性。丹妮卡想知道
what happened to Concierge Marie. He hooked up with Concierge Marie. Was this perhaps a deleted scene? Yes, it's in deleted scenes. They call Concierge Marie from the car. Here, here's the clip. Concierge, Jess, how may I help you? By going to the doctor and getting tested for herpes. Done. And in the shooting draft, it went on to say, with an asterisk, for the super fans, this is clearly a different Concierge. And after they hang up on her, Dwight crosses the Canadian off the list. Amazing. Well, now that Michael has confronted all of his former lovers, Dwight's going to see a real opportunity here. It's in deleted scenes, you guys. He's really, really pushing his cousin Shirley onto Michael. Oh, have a listen. Full disclosure,
礼宾员玛丽发生了什么事。他和礼宾员玛丽好上了。这也许是一个被删减的场景吗？是的，在删减片段里。他们从车里给礼宾员玛丽打了电话。来，这是片段。礼宾员，杰斯，我能帮你什么吗？去看医生并做疱疹检查。好的。在拍摄剧本中，它接着说，带有一个星号，对于超级粉丝来说，这显然是另一个礼宾员。在他们挂断电话后，德怀特把加拿大人从名单上划掉了。太棒了。嗯，既然迈克尔已经面对了他所有的前任情人，德怀特在这里看到了一个真正的机会。这在删减片段里，伙计们。他真的、真的在向迈克尔推销他的表妹雪莉。哦，听听看。完全披露，
I really was hoping to hook you up with my cousin Shirley. No, not Shirley. Do I just drop that? Okay, yeah, like a million times. She's really nice. Okay, I won't bring up Shirley anymore, but I just want to say that Holly has been holding you back. If you really put your mind to it, you could date a newscaster. I appreciate that. Thanks. Shirley's a newscaster. He's just going to keep pushing Shirley. I am so sad that we do not meet Dwight's cousin Shirley, the newscaster ever. I know. Oh, my mind is spinning with possibilities. This episode ends with Dwight and Michael telling Oscar they're pretty sure Michael has an ingrown mustache here, but they need to ask everyone Michael's kissed if they have
我真的希望能把你和我的表妹雪莉撮合在一起。不，不是雪莉。我只是放弃了吗？好吧，是的，像一百万次了。她人真的很好。好吧，我不会再提雪莉了，但我只想说霍莉一直拖累着你。如果你真的用心，你可以和新闻主播约会。我很感激。谢谢。雪莉就是新闻主播。他只是会一直推销雪莉。我很难过我们从来没有见过德怀特的表妹雪莉，那个新闻主播。我知道。哦，我的脑海里充满了各种可能性。这一集以德怀特和迈克尔告诉奥斯卡他们很确定迈克尔这里长了内生胡须结束，但他们需要问迈克尔亲吻过的每个人她们是否
had herpes. They won a list of all of Oscar's lovers. That's right. Oscar walks out the room. And that, my friends, is sex ed. I really enjoyed this episode. I loved every second of it. A big thank you to Randy Cordray and James Carey for helping us uncover some fun tidbits for this episode. Yes, Randy, thanks for the last minute emails before your vacation. It's so nice of you. We hope you guys have a great week and we'll see you next week with The Sting. Oh, it's a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher.
得过疱疹。他们想要一份奥斯卡所有情人的名单。没错。奥斯卡走出了房间。而那，我的朋友们，就是性教育。我真的很喜欢这一集。我喜欢它的每一秒。非常感谢兰迪·科德雷和詹姆斯·凯里帮助我们挖掘这一集的一些有趣花絮。是的，兰迪，谢谢你在度假前的最后一刻发来的邮件。你真是太好了。我们希望你们这周过得愉快，我们下周会带着《刺》这一集回来。哦，那是一集好戏。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。
Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需Stitcher Premium的一个月免费试用，请使用代码OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。